Three,
two,
boom.
We're live.
How are you sir?
I'm very good,
Joe.
It's good to meet you,
man.
Great to meet you and thank you very
much for doing this.
I've learned more about coyotes over the
last couple of months reading your book
and listening to your podcast with my
good friend Steve Rinella,
which was amazing.
Whew.
What a crazy animal that is.
You know,
I have coyotes all around my
neighborhood and uh,
it became a very,
very close to me when I saw one of my
chickens get captured by a coyote and I
watched him hop the fence with a chicken
in his mouth,
like God damn as motherfuckers and just
all around us especially.
I live in a fairly rural area around
here.
I'm about 40 minutes outside of La,
so it's,
you know,
the nights are quiet and you hear him
screaming in the night and I didn't know
much about them until I started reading
your book,
man.
Yeah,
they're amazing animal.
I mean,
I think,
uh,
there's not really another mammal side
from us that has a biography like these
animals do and that's kind of one of the
reasons I got fascinated with them.
Uh,
they were doing the same thing around me
when I was a kid growing up in
Louisiana.
I mean,
and that's sort of the beginning of my,
uh,
my getting captivated by these little
small wolves because they were suddenly
showing up in the bayous and swamps of
Louisiana when I was 12,
13,
14 years old.
And as far as I knew this was an animal
that was supposed to be in the deserts
of the West.
And so that seemed to be something that,
you know,
commanded one's attention that this
critter is,
is appearing in places where you would
never expect it.
And now of course everybody in the
country is dealing with them.
That is so fascinating that in our
lifetime they have spread from the
American southwest to every single state
and literally every single city in the
country.
Yeah,
that's true.
And I just got A.
Somebody sent me this yesterday,
that somewhere in Georgia they have some
sort of a bounty on these wolves.
Coyotes.
That's one thing a lot of people don't
realize that a coyote is a wolf.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a separate species from gray wolves
and red wolves,
but it's out of the North American wolf
line.
Uh,
I mean,
coyotes are distinctive,
laid North American animals.
They come out of Canada evolution that
began here five point 3 million years
ago.
So,
um,
yeah,
they're,
they're small wolves.
And I sent you this,
Jamie know,
you found it beautiful.
This is the Georgia coyote challenge.
Apparently they're offering some sort of
bounty for each coyote killed.
Now what's fascinating about this,
and one of the things that I learned
from your book is that when a coyote
yells,
when they're doing their call in the
night,
they're essentially making roll call and
when of them doesn't
respond,
the female generates more pups.
Yeah.
It's,
it's one of the,
you know,
one of the many things that's probably
happening when they're,
when they're howling,
I mean they are taking a census
basically of coyote populations in the
area.
And the result of,
of that census can very well be,
it produces some sort of a chemical or
metabolic change in,
in the females,
the breeding females,
the Alpha ones,
and they end up oftentimes having larger
litters of pumps,
which is why something like this,
you know,
I was just in South Carolina two weeks
ago and there was a lot of conversation
about this,
this Georgia bounty because in South
Carolina it's another place where
coyotes are,
are fairly new.
I've only been there in the last 20 or
25 years.
They were arguing that,
you know,
and they had some pretty good science
that coyotes are taking,
you know,
in some areas as many as 60 percent of
the white tail deer fawns.
And so the hunters are screaming along a
lot about this because it means it's
getting harder to take a white tail.
Um,
so South Carolina hasn't moved to the
step that Georgia has of trying to
impose some kind of bounty and encourage
people to go out and shoot these
animals,
uh,
to take them in any way they can,
but mostly shoot them.
Uh,
but,
you know,
I think the states in the south and in
the east have a lot to learn by the
western or from the Western experience
because the truth is we've been trying
to eradicate and I mean totally
exterminate coyotes in the American
west.
Uh,
we spent the years from about Nineteen
15 through about 1972 in an all out war
attempting to exterminate them.
And the only result of that,
uh,
as a result of their particular kinds of
adaptations in their evolution in North
America,
uh,
is that we spread them across the entire
country.
We not only spread them across the
entire country,
I mean they're in every state.
They colonize their 49th state,
Delaware in 2010.
So the only state,
they're not in his Hawaii just because
they have a stowed away and made it
across the Pacific yet.
And uh,
you know,
I mean if they do,
you can imagine those endangered
Naynay's on the big island are totally
done for.
But they are not only at every single
state in the union except for awhile,
but they are 7,000 miles now,
north and south and North America from
above the Arctic circle all the way down
to Central America and beginning to
colonize into South America.
So the attempts to exterminate them,
I mean I can explain how this,
why this happens,
has to do with their evolution in the
particular adaptations they have,
but the attempts to exterminate them or
even to try to control their numbers
almost always produces exactly the
opposite effect.
So Georgia is going to end up with more
coyotes than they've ever had before in
their efforts to try to suppress their
population.
Isn't that fascinating?
And it is.
It's so contrary to logic and what you
would think would be the solution for
something like that.
I mean,
and when you go back to the American
west,
before the reintroduction of wolves into
yellowstone in the 19 nineties,
we had essentially extirpated them from
a vast majority of the United States.
There's very,
very few left,
right?
That's true.
And the,
we'll see if he could believe,
explained the relationship that the gray
wolves had to the coyotes,
which is one of the reasons that the
coyotes became so adaptable.
It's true.
I mean,
they didn't.
Coyotes didn't become so smart,
you know,
and in the southwest,
the Hispanics say the only thing that's
smarter than a coyote is God,
but they didn't become that smart and
that adept,
that surviving anything almost that
happens to them.
Um,
because of us,
I mean,
we've only been trying to wipe them out
or control their populations for a
little more than a century nouse.
And that's too short a time for them to
evolve these abilities to adapt and
survive.
They,
they evolved those abilities because
they were the small dog and a big dog's
world.
And I mean gray wolves have this very
interesting story to gray wolves come
out of North American kainate evolution,
but they're one of the Canaan species
that ended up leaving North America for
a time and evolving for a couple of
million years in Asia and in Europe.
And they didn't come back.
A gray wolves didn't start coming back
to North America till about 25 or 30,000
years ago during sort of the height of
the late pleistocene and when they did,
coyote is of course had been here and
had evolved into their present species
about 800,000 to a million years ago.
And when gray wolves returned,
I mean they basically just started
kicking the crap out of coyotes.
And so coyotes evolve their ability to
survive being harassed and persecuted as
a result of being a basically harassed
by gray wolves.
So this is why when you hear about the
Coi Wolf that you hear on the east
coast,
this is a,
a coyote that bread with the red wolf
and,
and other eastern wolves,
correct?
That's correct.
Yeah.
And that's,
I mean,
it's a very interesting story and it's
kind of one of those instances where a
modern event that we're all getting to
witness the emergence of the Coi.
Wolf has its origins in the evolution of
mammals in North America,
a million years or more because the
raisin,
I mean,
if you think about this,
the reason coyotes,
red wolves and other eastern wolves like
the Algonquin Wolf,
uh,
in eastern Canada and,
and northern New England,
the reason those animals can all hybrid
eyes and readily do,
I mean they,
there are no behavioral barriers at all
to them breeding with one another.
And so whenever a coyote shows up,
um,
and it's in the vicinity of a,
an Algonquin Wolf,
say a female that comes into heat,
I mean,
she'll readily pick a coyote as a mate.
But the reason they do that is because
those animals,
red wolves,
eastern wolves of various kinds and
coyotes all seemed to have come out of a
group of animals that unlike the gray
wolf never left North America and they
probably didn't separate from one
another until 300,000 to a half million
years ago.
So that separation is recent enough that
whenever they encounter one enough with
one another today,
they very readily hybridize.
I mean,
it's sort of the result of coyote
spreading across the south has
essentially kind of killed our hope that
we were going to save the endangered red
wolf as an independent species because
red wolf so quickly and easily
hybridized with coyotes that coyote
genes swamp pure red wolf jeans.
So I mean that's something that you
know,
is millions of years or hundreds of
thousands of years old and evolution,
but we're getting to see it play out
right around us in our own time.
And meanwhile,
gray wolves and coyotes in the West
aren't hybridizing it all.
And so that's the explanation is that
gray wolves left and didn't come back
until why left?
Well,
they,
they just,
they happen to be in evolutionary terms.
One of the groups and jackals did the
same thing that they ended up leaving
North America and in their absence,
while they were in another part of the
world,
they evolved into the present
subspecies.
We've got four subspecies of gray wolves
in North America,
all of which seemed to have come back to
North America by the way,
at different times.
So they had sort of separate migrations
back to North America.
So the Mexican Gray Wolf,
uh,
the,
the western gray wolf,
the Arctic Wolf,
these are all gray wolf species,
but they're separated at the sub
specific level and they all seem to have
come back to North America at different
times.
But they,
they had left North America like about
three and a half million years ago.
And so they became different animals in
Asia and Europe by the time they came
back then they were different enough
from coyotes that they not only couldn't
interbreed with them anymore,
but they sort of are mortal enemies of
one another.
I mean,
when we reintroduced wolves to
yellowstone in 1995,
coyotes had,
had 75 years in yellowstone without any
wolves.
I mean,
and that served as a wonderful
laboratory to study them too because it
gave us a sense of what happens with
coyotes when nobody is harassing them
when people are harassing him,
which of course we didn't in yellowstone
park and when wolves aren't harassing
them either.
And what we realize is that they create
these really stable territory's.
They create very stable packs and their
population rises to a particular point,
the carrying capacity of the landscape
based on what they eat,
which is mostly rodents and rabbits and
things and some fruit and berries,
but it doesn't.
They don't.
Their population sort of levels off and
stays at a carrying capacity.
And so we got to watch that happen in
yellowstone for like 75 years and it's
become sort of the,
the example of what would happen if we
just left them alone.
I mean some people think,
well,
if we don't try to control them how
they're gonna,
you know,
they're just going to be millions upon
millions of them running everywhere,
but that's actually.
They only do that when you try to
persecute them and they go into this
colonization mode and generate more and
more and more pups and have more and
more pups survive.
So yellowstone in that period from 19,
25 to 1995 was this sort of model of
what happens when you just leave them
the hell alone and they just kind of
rise to a particular population level
and are really stable at that level.
And uh,
and don't really go beyond it and they
don't expand their territory that we
either know.
They don't seem to.
I mean,
one of the things that has happened
obviously in the last a hundred years or
so last 75 years at least,
is that as a result of persecuting them,
we've sent them into this kind of
colonization strategy where they,
they have larger litter of pups when
their populations are suppressed,
it's easier for them to get the pumps
that they do have to adulthood.
I mean in yellowstone for example,
one of the things we saw in that period
when they weren't being harassed in the
60 seventies,
eighties is that they would have a
litter of five or six pups and they
could only get a couple of them to
adulthood.
But whenever you try to control their
populations and momentarily suppressed
their populations,
I mean,
the result is that there's no more food
for coyotes out there for the coyotes
that,
that have survived.
And that makes it possible for them to
have a litter of seven or eight pups and
get six to seven of them to adulthood.
And then they have this,
this marvelous ability,
I mean,
I talk about it a good bit in the book,
it's called fish and fusion there,
one of the few species and we happened
to be one of the other mammal species
around the world that does this,
where they have the ability to exist as
a social animal and a case of coyotes as
a pack animal of course.
But whenever they're pressured,
they tend to split apart into singles
and pairs and they scatter across the
landscape and that's what sends them
colonizing across the continent.
The fact that they can do that is what
separates them really from wolves.
Right.
And that's why they weren't able to wipe
them out in the west.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I mean.
If you think about what happened with
gray wolves,
I mean we started,
uh,
the sort of in a decided effort to
eliminate gray wolves from the American
West in roughly.
I mean,
we started just ordinary people started
putting out strychnine bait for them in
the 18,
16 and 18 seventies.
But was it ranchers at first it started
that it was it because of livestock?
Yeah,
it was ranchers and just travelers on
the Oregon trail,
on the emigrant trails.
I mean people sort of regarded because
they came out of Europe with a
background with wolves.
I mean,
that's,
that's one of the things that
distinguishes us Americans and coyotes
is that we didn't have coyotes in
Europe,
so we didn't arrive with this preloaded
preconception about the role that
[inaudible] played in the world,
but we did with animals like bears and
wolves.
And so people just from the very
beginning,
whenever the Atlantic seaboard was
settled,
uh,
there were wolf drives and wolf roundups
and every kind of attempt to wipe out
wolves as competitors with us,
for our stock.
So in the west,
people just through strychnine bait out,
let me.
Strychnine was invented in Pennsylvania
in 18,
48 and it was widely available,
uh,
in places like Missouri when you set out
across the West and people would just
buy a bunch of baits.
I mean they would,
if they hung around long enough to get
the animal,
they would skin it and try to sell the
pill,
but they just poisoned them like crazy.
Then in starting in Nineteen 15,
this government agency called the bureau
of biological survey,
which positions itself as the solution
to predators first decides that it's the
wolf that we need to take out and I mean
they managed to take out the the last
probably quarter million wolves in the
West in the space of a little more than
a decade and they do it as you just
mentioned,
primarily because wolves are such pack
animals,
so pack oriented that if you could kill
our trap one member of a pack,
you could use the scent from that animal
and ended up catching every single
animal in the pack,
but coyotes responded to that kind of
pressure in a very different way.
I mean,
when you started pressuring them,
they tended,
their packs tended to break up.
They tended to scatter and go into this
fish mode and so indeed,
as you said a minute ago,
that's exactly why we were able to take
out wolves.
By the middle of the 19 twenties,
we pretty much had resolved the wolf
issue in the west,
but year after year after year as wolf
numbers a decline.
I mean,
I'll offer an example in Montana,
for instance,
18,
99,
the State of Montana boundaried 23,000
wolves.
I was 18,
99,
21 years later by 1920.
They only paid bounties on 17 gray
wolves because they had basically wiped
them out and then the government agency,
the biological survey came in and
cleaned up all the rest of them,
but every year from 1899 slash 19 slash
21 and right on into the 19 thirties in
Montana,
they were bouncing 30,000 coyotes in 18,
99 and 1910.
30,000 coyotes and 1918,
33,000 coyotes.
I mean the number of coyotes never
dropped while wolf populations just
plummeted.
Data is so fascinating.
What a crazy little animal that is.
It is.
It's a.
it's so wonderfully counterintuitive in
the whole kind of environmental story of
America because what you always expect
is that anytime we put our mind to
taking on some creature and,
and taking it out,
I mean we can do it.
I mean,
you know,
the only time this never really happened
was in Moby Dick where captain Ahab is
driven mad by his inability to control
the great white whale and the control of
nature and that in a lot of places that
seems to be where we,
we land when people realized that you
can't do anything about coyotes,
it Kinda drives people out of their
minds because this is just not the
American way.
We can always deal with an animal.
Yeah,
it is a,
it's got to be very frustrating to
people and a lot of ways,
but it's,
it's kind of amazing.
I mean,
it's really kind of magical and a lot of
ways that,
that they're so,
they're so adaptable and that all came,
you're saying because of their
relationship with the gray wolf.
Now how do we know that the gray wolf
left?
Well,
we know that they're still wolves in
America.
Uh,
there's no question about that.
And so,
I mean,
that is a tricky question.
there is a,
you know,
so I would hasten to say,
first of all,
I'm not a geneticist.
I'm not even a biologist.
I'm basically an environmental writer
and somebody who uses history a lot,
um,
and there is unresolved science out
there and buy what I mean.
What I mean by that is that there are a
couple of different camps that have
advanced positions about the
relationship between all these different
wolves that we have in North America and
coyotes.
So there is a guy at Ucla,
I'm here in Los Angeles.
Uh,
his name was Robert Wayne,
uh,
and he has done a genetic work on chain
[inaudible].
I'm,
one of his papers is called,
uh,
the title includes the phrase and
Magmatic Wolf,
like Canids,
and he's done the genetic analysis on
coyotes,
red wolves,
gray wolves,
and eastern wolves.
And his argument is that
gray wolves,
red wolves,
and eastern wolves are all actually some
version of gray wolves.
So that's a different argument than the
one that I made for you just a few
minutes ago.
I've been following,
and I've followed in my book because I
found it a more compelling argument,
one advanced by a group of geneticists
from Canada,
led by a guy named Paul Wilson.
And that's the,
that's the position that the US fish and
wildlife service and it's endangered
species division takes.
And their argument is that the gray wolf
is a separate animal from the Red Wolf,
the eastern wolf,
and the coyote,
they,
they argue that coyotes,
red wolves,
and eastern wolves all come out of a
clade,
the biological term,
c,
l a,
d,
e,
a clade of animals that are purely North
American in origin.
And that had a,
probably a similar ancestor as recently
as maybe 300,000 years to 500,000 years
ago.
So we've got two different arguments
about the relationship of coyotes to two
worlds and I don't know who's going to
win it,
but one of the reasons I tend to sort of
favor the,
the Paul Wilson Line of argument and the
one that the US fish and wildlife
service is using is because they use
some,
they use evidence beyond just genetics.
They also use morphology and they use
fossils.
Uh,
and uh,
Robert Wayne and the group,
a geneticists who work with him all
seemed just rely specifically on
genetics.
And they don't ever try to verify there
findings by looking at the fossil
record,
for example.
Um,
so I don't know how it's going to play
out between these two groups,
but I find the argument,
the Canadian geneticists that has
informed the US fish and wildlife
services strategy a little bit more
compelling right now.
But I mean,
it's something to pay attention to.
We'll see how it goes.
Well,
it seems like you,
you need some sort of a really
comprehensive way of looking at it
because you're dealing with so many
different factors,
right?
If you're trying to acquire evidence
based on 25,000 years ago,
it seems like there's got to be a lot of
different ways.
It just,
it's very odd to me that we know as much
as we do.
No,
I mean in to try to figure it all out as
got to be incredibly frustrating when
you're dealing with so little evidence
and you're looking at the fossil record.
I mean a lot of the animals that die
25,000 years ago,
there's zero evidence of them,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
I mean,
a 25,000 years ago,
for example,
and the light pleistocene,
uh,
the evidence from labrea tar pit
indicates that coyotes were a slightly
different animal than they are now.
They were,
uh,
at the time we think gray wolves were
coming back into North America,
returning to their evolutionary
homeland.
Coyotes were much bigger,
more strapping,
had larger dentition,
stronger jaws.
And what looks like happened is when
gray wolves arrived in the west and
began competing with these larger,
more strapping coyotes,
coyotes sort of sought a different path.
They,
they sort of stepped back away from
outright competition with an even bigger
Canaan and evolved into a smaller,
more grass.
I'll animal that was not so much just a
pure Predator and scavenger,
but more omnivorous and so became our
modern canus,
lutron's species.
But yeah,
it's a.
and I was,
we'll say,
you know,
as you mentioned a minute ago,
I mean,
it's hard to know all of this.
Much of this information is fairly
recent.
I mean,
we just got a kind of a reappraisal of
the taxonomy of the North American
wolves essentially in the last seven or
eight or 10 years.
Our other wolves omnivorous,
or is it just coyotes?
Well,
wolves can be omnivorous,
but they're,
they're pretty much really a carnivorous
pack.
Predators.
I find coyote crap in my yard all the
time and it's got berries in it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Like they eat a lot of these little red
berries that grow out here.
Yeah.
They,
they eat juniper's.
I mean,
the same thing is happening at all.
My place in New Mexico starting
essentially about in August or
September,
all the coyote droppings that I've found
on the place.
I mean,
and I've got a lot of coyotes on my
place in New Mexico,
uh,
has just been filled with juniper
berries.
That's what they've been eating.
I mean they,
they still are,
you know,
running down rabbits and eating rats and
mice and things.
But I mean,
when they move into cities,
they tend to eat and they have access to
fruit trees.
They tend to eat a lot of fruit.
So they'll,
I mean,
you know,
that people have posted photos on the
internet or youtube videos that show
them plucking apples and peaches and
things off trees in their backyards and
they really go for that sort of stuff.
So bizarre.
It was just such a strange animal.
And so do we know if wolves do anything
like that or is it just a coyote
characteristic?
It's pretty much a coyote
characteristic.
I mean,
you know,
as,
as we've been saying,
the coyote in an evolutionary sense is
a,
a small wolf.
Um,
but it is different,
especially from gray wolves.
And one of the ways it's different,
uh,
that the biologist and the
behavioralists who have watched coyotes
interact with one another and watch gray
wolves interact with one another,
is an indication of how much more pack
oriented Hanse sort of predatory
carnivorous wolves are wolves because
they exist mostly as despite our,
in our cultural motif of the lone wolf.
Actually,
wolves are such pack animals that they
have a much wider range of expressions
that they convey to one another in their
interactions with one another.
And they,
uh,
they basically will sort of engage with
one another and a repertoire of grimaces
and grands and showing their teeth are
curling their lip.
Of course,
all sorts of body language were they
curl their tails under a and they'll
drop their heads and drop her ears.
Coyotes have a similar repertoire,
but it's a much more limited one.
And the argument that the behavioralists
make is that that's an indication of an
animal that's not so packed oriented.
It's not living exclusively in a social
group.
It can go off on its own or as a pair
and therefore doesn't really need all
those facial expressions to convey
emotion.
So how do we know that that all these
animals,
all these canids evolved in North
America and then spread out and went to
Asia and Africa and all these different
places?
Well,
that's out of the fossil record.
Um,
and I mean there's a,
there's a good science in the fossil
record of candidate evolution.
As I said a bit ago.
It seems to go back to about five point
3 million years ago.
And all the cane is all around the world
seem to have come out of this,
this singular origin much the way all
the primates of the world came out of an
origin in Africa.
And so,
you know,
and the horses,
for instance,
same thing,
horses came out of an evolutionary
origin in North America and then spread
across the land bridges to become zebras
in Africa for instance.
And so that's how it happened.
And uh,
some of these,
these animals like jackals for example,
the golden jackals seemed to have
separated from the small chain Id,
the coyote,
the line that led to coyote is about a
million years ago and it crossed the
land bridge into Africa,
Southern Europe,
parts of Asia,
and became an animal that never returned
in North America.
And because of its separation from
coyotes by a million years,
it became a,
a different creature.
So crazy.
They all did that on foot.
Yeah,
they did it somehow know that
the animal came from North America and
made it all the way to Africa.
And I want to bring something up that
you talked about just now.
The horses evolved in North America and
became zebras.
Yeah,
I mean all that started here,
but then they weren't here anymore and
then they were reintroduced to the
native Americans by the Europeans.
And what happened to the horses that
were here?
Well,
that's one of the great mysteries of a
North American evolution,
actually,
I,
a frank answer is we don't really know
what happened to them.
And so this is,
um,
you know,
maybe somebody out there listening,
Joe in the next 10 or 15 years,
we'll solve it.
It will solve this problem because here
we have a group of animals whose
evolutionary.
I'm in case of the horse.
They're evolutionary origins.
Go back 56 million years in North
America,
so 10 times a greater depth and time
than,
than the canids do.
And so they're here in all sorts of
forms.
Everyone has heard,
you know,
the three toed horse,
I'm a Eo.
Hipaa says what it's called now that
gradually becomes bigger and,
uh,
it's hooves fused together and they
become hardened because it's running
over rocky ground.
And so it has to have hard hooves.
And because it begins to,
it starts as a browsing animal in the
forest and ultimately becomes a
grassland animal and it's eating grasses
that are often coated with windblown
sand.
So it has to evolve very strong and hard
and namel and on its teeth in order
resists having its being eroded down by
San.
It becomes ultimately by 15,
20,000 years ago,
an animal that we would not be able to
tell a would be any different from a
modern horse.
It would look exactly like a modern
horse,
same size.
I mean I've seen skeletons of some of
the horses that were in North America
down to about 11,000 years ago.
And even the paleontologists would have
a hard time telling,
which was the skeleton of a North
American Horse Inn,
which was the skeleton of a modern
domestic horse.
But these animals had had traveled
across the land,
bridges the bering land bridge when it
was open and had ended up in Asia and
Africa and Europe where they survived.
But for some bizarre reason,
sometime between about 10,000 years ago
and 8,000 years ago and North America,
they disappeared.
They completely went extinct in North
America and so when we Europeans
returned them to North America 500 years
ago,
one of the reasons they become such a
success and just spread across the
western part of the continent and
multiply into the millions is because
they're already pre adapted to the
landscape.
This is where they had evolved.
And so they've already got the hooves.
They've got the teeth,
they've got the running ability that he
got the bill to buck off predators and
they get back here in North America and
within the space of about a,
after they get loose from the Pueblo
revolt in 1680,
within the space of about 50 to 60 or 70
years.
They're all the way up into Canada.
Uh,
and there are within 100 years,
probably as many as 2 million of them
spreading across the West reinhabiting
their own ecological niche.
They just fit like a glove,
fit like a glove man.
And um,
you know,
and they became an.
It's a fascinating thing to kind of
imagine because the West 10,
15,
25,000 years ago had been a place where
horses had made up and some parts of the
West as much of as a third of the
biomass of all the grazing animals and
in the 17 hundreds and 18 hundreds,
they were doing the same thing again.
They were multiplying into the hundreds
of thousands.
The millions gradually spreading New
Mexico is where the domestic European
horse got loose and began to spread and
they had reached all the way up into
Montana,
Wyoming into into the edges of Canada by
18,
50,
60 or so,
and had probably were at least two to 3
million of them at that point.
So they were just reinhabiting there.
Oh,
landscape and fitting into an ecology
now that had been dominated by bison for
a long time and now horses are back in
the mix.
And horses today are very controversial
animal.
Wild horses are in,
you know,
people trying to think of him as an
invasive species,
but essentially they're just a
reintroduce species.
And because of that,
there's a lot of controversy on how they
should be dealt with.
Like some people want to deal with them,
like almost like they deal with wild
pigs.
Yeah,
right.
Uh,
yeah.
And so,
you know,
there are plenty of people out there
who,
who argue that the domestic horse,
the feral horse in the west,
which is the root stock of most of our
population of wild horses in the West,
um,
you know,
is a,
essentially it's a European animal that
has become an invader.
Um,
I mean,
I always,
and I've had arguments on stage with
people who,
who,
uh,
expressed this position.
I always say,
well,
what you have to say about the horse,
first of all is that a,
it's a,
it's an American animal with an
asterisk.
It's gone for about eight or 9,000
years.
That's actually not a huge amount of
time in evolutionary terms.
And even though we did domesticate them
and began to produce some breeds,
horses left to their own devices pretty
quickly breed back to the wild look and
the wild state.
I mean,
they'll acquire those dorsal stripes
down their backs.
And Zebra striping on their legs.
And so zebra striping.
Oh yeah.
No,
absolutely.
Well,
is that.
There's a lot of controversy as to what
the Zebra striping is for.
Right?
Is it to distract predators of the idea
behind it?
It may have been that,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not quite sure I can say whether the
Zebra striping evolved for a specific,
a specific reason.
Although most changes and animals do,
but yeah,
they,
they will fairly readily go back to this
early wild horse look,
which is probably what horses looked
like in North America 10,000 years ago.
See if you can find some pictures of
like wild horses with Zebra stripes.
I don't think I've ever seen it.
Look,
look,
that's fascinating.
Yeah.
Look in the Pryor Mountains,
wild horse range in Montana and you'll
see a whole population of animals that
come out of that,
that background.
They have a very interesting history
because it was a group of animals that
Lewis and Clark acquired from the
Indians and they were going to take back
and trade in the Mandan villages,
uh,
and a guy named,
prior who was responsible for the herd,
was driving them through the today's
pryor mountains and the crow Indians
raided his camp and chased off a bunch
of those horses and they're now in those
mountains and they,
this early,
sort of a dorsal back striped zebra leg
look that probably came right from the
Spanish horses of New Mexico.
Wow.
Uh,
up into the northern West.
So the,
whatever,
the mass extinction event that took
place somewhere in the neighborhood of
10,000 years ago that claimed the wooly
mammoth,
saber tooth tiger,
all these different animals.
The horse was amongst that as well,
is that the horse was one of the ones
that disappeared.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
you know,
so I mean,
we've got some pretty good explanations
for what happened to the mammoths.
You know,
the mammas probably a were taken out by
human hunters because this,
this was a version of the American west
that,
that basically had emerged in the
absence of people,
you know,
and we're just like every other mammal
that you mentioned a minute ago.
You were amazed at the fact that the
wolves were able to spread around the
world and the horses were able to spread
around the world.
Well,
we did the same thing.
We started in Africa and we spread
around the world getting the Europe
about 45,000 years ago and didn't get to
North America,
which was one of the last places except
for the islands out in the Pacific that
humans got to until about 15,000 years
ago.
And so when we arrive,
we confronted a landscape that was full
of animals,
like mammoths that had no experience
with human hunters at all.
And what we think is that these early
arrivals from Siberia,
uh,
we're probably really accomplished big
game hunters.
And I mean,
like all elephants,
mammas had really long gestation
periods.
It took them once they were impregnated,
took them two years to have a calf.
Wow.
And so they have a really to pregnant
for two years.
Yeah,
they're pregnant for two years and so
they have a really low population
recovery ability,
a biologist call this a case species
that have a kind of a low reproductive
rate.
And so whenever humans arrive and you
know,
and we take a look at the situation,
and I mean cow mammoths evidently were a
lot easier to deal with in a hunt then
the big bulls were.
And so these hunter seemed to have
concentrated on cows.
I mean that's of course obviously going
to be detrimental to the demographics of
the population.
And so probably in the case of mammoths,
it was human hunting of an animal that
had no prior experience with human
hunters then.
And not very many defenses against us
that took them out.
The other animals that have a lot of
them,
I mean some of the predators we think
they went because of their prey species
disappeared.
But I mean,
the amazing thing with the horses is
just hard to fathom because we haven't
found very many sites.
There was one recently near Boulder,
Colorado of what appeared to be on early
Indian kill of horses.
But you know,
if you tried to argue that the same
thing happened with horses that happen
with the Mammas,
she'd think you'd be finding kill sites
all over the place.
It's not really found them.
Have you ever looked into as this one of
the animals?
So it's got the front paws got a little
bit of zero strikes her front legs
rather.
But you,
you're saying it's the back legs?
Well,
it's both,
so I'll look at that.
Wow,
that's fascinating.
Yeah.
They had the zebra stripes on the legs
and.
Oh Wow.
That is wild.
And they have this black stripe down the
back.
The dorsal stripe is king.
So yeah.
Well,
I've read something about zebras that
they're,
um,
that it makes it very hard for predators
to differentiate between individual
zebras and that they had put an ear
collar or clip on one of the zebras and
immediately that Zebra was taken out and
they had singled that zebra out.
It was very obvious to the predators
that,
that was an individual and they went
right after it.
Yeah.
Well,
it could be something like that.
And I mean it's pretty clear from the
North American horses that the Zebra
striping trait originated here and then
ended up being taken by the animals that
migrated into Africa and perhaps
elaborated on over time where they're
dealing with,
with lions and Cheetahs and leopards and
things like that.
And they handled lion in North America.
Yeah.
We had lauren time that was even bigger
than the African lions,
right.
Panthera,
the step line was a line that was one
and a half times the size of,
of the African Lion.
And we had a,
you know,
a short face bear that was probably even
more ferocious than modern day grizzlies
for one thing.
It seems to have been a this really
gracile animal.
It looked far more nimble and fast and
its ability to run and so forth.
Then Grizzlies do.
Yeah.
We've talked about that thing many times
since I heard you talk about and we
pulled up pictures of it and the size of
the things and the length of the legs.
Yeah,
and I looked at.
It's a huge animal that's a huge animal,
was bigger than a polar bear,
so I.
there's A.
There's a Canadian biologist named
hilarious guys who has argued for a long
time that he thinks until short faced
bears became extinct.
Humans were not able to actually
colonized North America,
that those things were so fearsome that
they basically kept Siberian hunters at
bay on the other side of the bering land
bridge and finally when they began to
disappear,
then people begin trekking across and
getting it in North America.
Wow.
Well,
they look like a monster.
I mean,
it doesn't even look like a real animal.
It looks like something in a movie and
then you see the short face and what is
that next
day it.
How do you say that?
Don Dale.
Don,
that's what do they call that?
The hell pig?
Yeah,
that's a,
an animal even bigger than the short
face bear.
So all these animals that existed in
North America,
when did the short face bear go extinct?
The size of that thing.
That's terrifying.
Yeah.
I think probably about,
uh,
about 14,000,
15,000 years ago and as I said,
at least one biologist argues that it's
no coincidence that that's about the
time that humans began showing up is
that once this bear is,
has gone,
then it makes it possible for people to
come into North America because they're
a hypothesis as to why that went extinct
because of human intervention as well.
Now,
you know,
I think what's happening,
uh,
in,
there's a bunch of pretty wild swings in
climate,
uh,
as a result of the,
the steady progression of ice ages and
then water called,
uh,
the Inter pluvial in between the ice
ages and the reason we think we have
sort of a steady record of ice ages and
then a warming period in between and
then a return to ice ages.
And warming,
and that goes back on the record for a
very long time,
is that the earth actually doesn't spin
a and a true,
perfect spin on its axis.
It has a wobble in it and sometimes when
it wobbles,
this is called a procession of the
equinoxes.
Well,
it's called the,
uh,
the milankovitch cycles of a European.
Uh,
I can't remember if he was a geographer,
probably a geographer was the first to
speculate that this is why we have this
climate history of a procession between
ice ages and pluvial is in between,
is because the earth wobbles and as it
wobbles,
it will at certain times position the
northern hemisphere farther away from
the sun for a period of 30,
40,000 years.
And during that wobble and that
position,
you get a,
an ice age.
And then the wobble,
we'll take it back so that the northern
hemisphere begins to point more directly
at the sun.
And in between you get what are called
[inaudible].
Uh,
sometimes quite warm episodes.
I mean,
we had one about 5,000 years ago.
That was probably six or seven or eight
degrees warmer than today.
I would love to get you together with a
guy named Randall Carlson,
who's an expert in astro asteroidal
impacts and he's got some pretty
compelling evidence and some fascinating
theories about the end of the ice age
and at the end of the ice age
corresponds to a lot of nuclear glass
sites in Asia and Europe that the
nuclear glasses as essentially the same
stuff they find doing.
They do nuclear test sites.
That also happens when they have media
impacts and it's all throughout and
Europe
and he believes there was a significant
impact in North America.
Not once but twice and it directly
corresponds to our,
a planet passing through a essentially a
comet storm.
Really fascinating stuff,
but he's got this.
Actually,
I would love to get you together with
him because he's got some compelling
evidence that he believes that the wooly
mammoths and the,
what was it,
60 something percent of the large
mammals that died off during that very
distinct time period.
He says that directly corresponds to
physical evidence of this trite night
stuff and all these,
uh,
diamonds that they find micro diamonds
that come from these impacts.
Very fascinating.
It is a possibility that you have
considered
no.
Well,
I mean I've read about it and I think,
you know,
as in so many questions out there,
we haven't figured out the answers to
things and a lot of instances.
And so yeah,
this is a possibility.
I mean,
what I was sort of leading to by
tracking that milankovitch cycle,
a procession through time is that that
sort of changed tends to produce among
animal species and plants to really a
lot of speciation.
In other words,
it generates a lot of new because you're
often isolating populations and when
populations get isolated from their
parent populations,
they'll evolve some new traits and maybe
even become a new species.
And so you get a lot.
It's kind of a cycle where you end up
with a lot of different new animals.
But when change comes,
you often lose a good many of them.
And so,
uh,
these extinctions scenarios that are
associated with the ice ages and the
[inaudible] in between the
interglacials,
uh,
do tend to produce quite a number of
extinctions.
And the short face bear,
I mean I wish I was more of an expert so
I could directly address exactly what
happened to it.
But all I can tell you from my limited
knowledge of it is that it seems to have
disappeared in North America around
15,000 years ago.
And that's at a time when the Wisconsin
ice age is beginning to wind down.
Um,
and so,
you know,
we still haven't.
I mean,
there are a lot of scholars out there,
a lot of people out there who are
arguing climate as the primary
explanation for the Pleistocene
extinctions.
Most people sort of concede that,
okay,
in the case of the mammoths are evidence
tends to point more towards human
hunting,
but we don't know about all these other
animals.
You know why?
I mean the predators,
as I said,
they seem to disappear because of the
prey disappears.
But I mean one of the camels
disappeared.
One of the,
the,
you know,
these giant ground sloths disappear when
the things that they ate.
The Globe mallows that are still in the
West are still out there.
But the animal that fed on them isn't
there anymore,
so it's something,
you know,
that people have been sort of a
hammering around over beers and in
laboratories for actually more than a
century now.
And we still haven't answered all the
questions.
It is
fascinating,
but it's so amazing that you could even
formulate that much information based on
something that was 25,
15,000 years ago.
It is,
I mean,
this whole country that we,
we live in today was for,
as far as Europeans are concerned,
we've only been here a few hundred
years,
which is really kind of amazing.
I've only been here for a few hundred
years,
you know,
and uh,
I mean,
as you know from,
from the,
uh,
the other recent book of mine,
American Serengeti,
uh,
one of the animals that you can observe
today that gives us maybe our best sense
of what the Pleistocene is light is the
pronghorn antelope,
which is still out on the plains.
And of course across a lot of the west,
I mean natural where they nearly
disappeared at the turn of the 20th
century.
We've managed to bring them back and a
lot of western states,
but that's an animal that is essentially
a holdover from the pleistocene and is
kind of still fighting pleistocene
ghosts.
I mean,
it's an animal is everybody knows that
can run 65 miles an hour and yet for the
last 10,000 years,
the fastest animal that can chase it.
The Gray Wolf only runs 45 miles an
hour.
And so that leads to the obvious
question why the overkill in terms of
speed,
what you would think is all you need to
do is run 47 miles an hour and you got
it covered.
But here are these animals still among
us that runs 65 miles an hour,
that can't jump over fences that still
congregate and what,
uh,
what people call the selfish herd where
they'll group up as a herd of adults and
the dominant animals will end up in the
middle so that if there are any
predators,
they get the ones on the edges and the
dominant ones survive.
And yet they don't have any predators
except as fons.
And so what we think is happening is
that in the pronghorn we've got an
animal that has survived in our own time
that preserves how evolution shaped it
to deal with the predators of the
Pleistocene,
when there actually was a cheetah and a
running hyena that could run almost 65
miles an hour and there were predators
that went after their herds when they
were adults,
and all those animals have disappeared.
They're all ghosts and have been for
10,000 years and yet pronghorn still
preserve the ability to run away from a
Cheetah and two group up as a selfish
herd and preserve the dominant animals
in the middle against the hyena attack.
I had no idea they could run that fast.
They can run 65 miles an hour.
I only think some of the females which
are a little bit lighter than the males
are.
Some of them may be able to run 70 magic
going on the highway.
You're.
You're violating the speed limit.
And a pronghorn process is.
Yes,
that's right.
That's incredible.
I did not know that there was hyenas
that lived in North America as well that
could run that fast.
Yeah.
We had a fast,
a running hyena that,
uh,
was a major Predator of creatures like
this,
you know,
I mean,
if you think about it,
what you know,
and this is why I use the term American
Serengeti for the title of this book,
what we had in North America where these
versions.
Yeah.
On the.
Look,
we've got a video of them right now and
just someone's driving in the car and
they are just flying by.
Yeah.
Merriweather Lewis famously said
they're,
they're running motion more resembles
the flight of birds than it does any
mammal.
Yeah,
I've seen them.
I saw them in Montana and boy did they
book.
It's Kinda crazy to watch in real life.
We'll see him take off when they get
spooked and you're like,
whoa.
There are version of,
you know,
impalas and gazelles and in Africa.
And so what other aunt there was this
Cheetah now?
Is it,
does it resemble the African Cheetah?
Was it?
Did it looked like an African Cheetah?
It,
it did.
Resemble it,
uh,
as a result of kind of convergent
evolution.
I mean,
it,
it was an animal that pursued these
pronghorns that could run 70 miles an
hour.
So it had to be able to run that fast.
Did it develop independently of the
African Cheetah?
It did end date.
And in fact it developed from the
Cougar,
the mountain lion line.
So it doesn't come out of,
you know,
I mean the,
the Cheetah is a cat that famously many
people say it.
It's a dog gleick cat,
uh,
and it's,
its own independent entity in Africa.
And so our version of it came out of the
same line that produced mountain lions
except Mountain Lions 15,000,
20,000 years ago.
Produced this very fast running version
that was in effect an American Cheetah.
Wow.
And did it have the same sort of front
paws as a cheetah?
Cause Cheetah's,
they're more,
almost dogleg this,
this,
this North American animal didn't have
dog like pads,
like the African Cheetah does a,
at least I'm not,
you know,
there may be some cheetah are our North
American cheese expert out there who
would,
who would contest that.
But I don't think so.
I've not seen any evidence anywhere in
anything I've read that it did.
So it essentially just develop
disability to run very fast,
to catch pronghorn
to catch pronghorns and catch,
you know.
And there were,
there were other animals that could run,
I mean,
horses run pretty fast,
so,
uh,
and cats,
I mean the reason horses buck of course,
which we translated in our own time into
Rodeo sports,
but the reason they buck is because
that's their strategy for dislodging a
cat attack.
They were always a pray of cats.
And so,
you know,
and so,
I mean,
when we were talking about horses a
minute ago,
I mean,
one of the points I was going to make,
and I can make this point too,
is that one of the reasons horses
reasons,
horses are an issue now.
And a problem in the West is a,
they're not on the great plains anymore,
which was the primary horse range during
the 17 hundreds and 18 hundreds there in
the deserts of places like Nevada.
Uh,
so they're in a much more arid country,
not in a lushly grass plains setting,
but in a,
in a desert setting,
and we don't have their predators around
anymore.
I mean,
we've taken out gray wolves,
which certainly did pray on colts.
We've almost wiped out mountain lions.
They're meant lines are coming back and
that's was always one of the major
predators of cults,
but horses don't have the sort of
predators anymore that they had during
the pleistocene or even in the 17
hundreds and 18 hundreds.
And so without their predators on the
landscape and also being out in a desert
setting rather than out in the much
lusher great plains.
They,
you know,
they've become an issue in terms of uh,
how they compete with cattle,
how they compete with sheep,
how they compete with mule deer and
wildlife.
And that's why we were sort of endlessly
rattling the cage around wild horses
now.
But in the 19th century,
in the 18 hundreds,
I mean,
were they were out on the great plains.
They were in eastern Montana and eastern
Colorado and eastern New Mexico in this
much more lushly grasp setting.
And they're,
of course still were wolves and mountain
lions to take out the colts and sort of
keep their population suppressed them,
it seems,
you know,
I mean,
I'm incredulous that human beings that
didn't even have bows and arrows could
kill off the woolly mammoth.
But then you stop and think about what
people are able to do in the few hundred
years that we've been here when we
arrived in North America,
when Europeans arrived in North America
and just essentially swept through the
country and almost extra painted
everything.
Found like white
tail deer,
antelope,
Buffalo.
We almost wiped the whole thing of elk
when we got it down to just,
I mean,
at the turn of the 19th century or the
20th century,
rather we.
It was a,
it was a sad state and it was a sad
state and it was a,
you know,
it's one of those instances in history
where a.
I mean,
I think I say this in the introduction
of that American Serengeti Book,
that that was the largest destruction of
wildlife that I've been able to discover
in world history when Europeans came to
North America and proceeded,
as you've just described from the
Atlantic seaboard to the Pacific and
essentially wiped out just dozens of
animal species in most instances.
Not completely a exterminating them,
but dropping them to numbers that were
so low that you know,
you worried that this animal was gonna
survive and I mean some animals.
We did go extinct.
The Carolina parakeet,
for example,
a,
was this beautiful Gadi Green and
yellow,
large cro sized parrot that was in North
America all the way up to the great
lakes and they became extinct by the 19
thirties people hunted them.
They were regarded as a agricultural
pest and so farmers basically killed
them and enlisted government agents as
had happened with wolves and coyotes to
their wiped them out.
It's fascinating and I guess it makes
sense,
but it's just fascinating that just a
few hundred years ago they lacked the
foresight to understand that any sort of
intrusion into the ecosystem,
any sort of,
you know,
eliminating one Predator or taking out
one thing causes a cascade of events
that can be disastrous.
Now.
People didn't know anything about
ecology.
I mean,
you know,
we don't have a emerge as a science
until the 18 sixties.
It may make sense,
but it's amazing.
It really is amazing and it knew so
little.
We knew,
we knew very little and we tended to,
you know,
I'm in with a complete lack of
knowledge.
I mean we did the same thing with the
coyote attempt at exterminating them.
We,
we pass a law in Congress in 1931 to
provide for the extermination of coyotes
into appropriate the money to do it.
I mean we spent probably $100,000,000
over the next 40 or 50 years attempting
to do it and pass that law at a time
when we'd never sent the first
scientists out to do any study of coyote
national history.
We had no idea what they ate,
had no clue about them,
but before we even have any science to
go on at all,
we just go ahead and take step up.
Okay.
We're going to.
This is an ammo.
We're to completely weed out of the
North American setting.
We're going to eliminate it.
I don't know a damn thing about it,
but we're gonna.
Make sure that this thing does not
survive through the 20th century.
It's fascinating in your book,
the accounts of the early explorers who
are trying to figure out what the hell a
coyote was.
They thought maybe it was a jackal.
They didn't know what it was,
and then they finally decided it was
some sort of a small wolf and in the
initial description of it,
where they call it a prairie wolfe
prairie wolf.
That's right.
Yeah,
fine in a lot of people don't know this
for most of the 19th century.
I mean I've.
I've seen references to this name as
late as 1915 Americans call coyotes.
Pray Wolf's.
That was the name Lewis and Clark gave
them.
And so that's what everybody called
And it wasn't until we started getting
out into the southwest,
uh,
in the 18,
40 [inaudible] and 18 fifties,
especially around Santa fe where there
were Indian people who had come up with
the Spanish colonization of the
southwest who spoke the language of the
Aztecs.
That language is called know what and
the word coyote comes from the Aztec
language.
So when Americans were first getting
into New Mexico in the 1840 [inaudible],
really they began encountering people
who are using a different name for the
animal.
And over the next 30 or 40 years,
that name sort of overtook the term
prairie wolf and finally completely
replaced it.
So the original name was an Aztec name.
Yeah.
It was an asset name.
And it's pronounced and in the know Hwat
language,
it's spelled and their language c o y o
t t l,
but the l on the end is silent.
And so the way they pronounced it was
quote.
And um,
I mean the Aztec language because they,
you know,
they were an empire and they,
they defeated a lot of peoples and they
imposed their language and their customs
on a lot of people.
There were all sorts of Indians who
weren't necessarily as check who spoke
that language,
uh,
and there were evidently a enough of
them in places like Santa Fe in Tucson
that when a Anglo Americans got out
there,
they,
they were encountering not only native
people who were using that word,
but the Spanish not being privy to the
American use of the term prairie wolf.
The Spanish had just adopted the Indian
name for the animal.
And they had hispanicized it.
And they began,
they gave it an extra syllable.
So they call the animal a coil pot.
And that's what these early Americans
were hearing.
They were largely hearing the Spanish
pronunciation,
the three syllable version,
Cota Ota and Mark Twain comes along and
the 18 seventies and writes a very
famous book about the West roughing it.
Of course,
he's America's most famous writer at the
time,
his book as best seller a and Mark
Twain,
not only kind of,
because we,
as you mentioned,
mentioned a minute ago,
we don't really know what to make of
these animals.
Americans have never had an experience
with an animal like this,
so we don't know what to think about
them.
Mark Twain is the one who provides us
with kind of a take on them as these
cowardly,
despicable a little creatures that have
this,
you know,
uh,
overgrown wolf skin and this is
despairing look.
And he says,
you know,
they're,
they're such scoundrels in such
scavengers that a flea would desert one
for a philosophy,
you know,
and he's.
Mark Twain is humorous.
So he gets on this riff and he goes on
for like three pages in this vein,
so that by the time you end up reading
it,
your basic conviction is,
okay,
this is a despicable creature that's
just breathing up good air.
So we should just get rid of it.
But he does.
In the course of that book,
tell Americans how,
what the animal is called and how you
pronounce it.
And he says,
uh,
in the west,
this animal is called a coyote and he
spelled it out phonetically given us our
modern pronunciation of coyote.
Saw our modern pronunciation comes from
Mark Twain.
Yeah,
he's,
well,
he's the one who at least popularizes
that.
And everybody who read his book
basically kind of,
I think a absorbed that pronunciation of
it.
Why did these native Americans have such
a great respect for the coyote?
Like what was it about that animal that
we created so many legends?
Oh,
that's a great story.
And as I argue in this book,
I mean,
I.
What I try to do with Coyote America is
to tell the,
the biography of the animal from its
evolutionary origins through its
history,
up until the present time when of course
it's in everybody's backyard all over
the country.
And so we're all all dealing with it and
having to figure out what it is and,
and how you coexist with it.
But it's a real rollercoaster ride
because I mean,
it goes,
you know,
for a million years of its evolution,
uh,
confronting at certain times the return
of gray wolves to North America,
which clearly don't like coyotes and
beat the crap out of them and even
probably influenced their evolutionary
direction into a smaller,
more jackal like animal.
But then it also,
it has this story that's associated with
us when humans arrive in North America.
I mean,
coyotes get this wonderful peer.
It lasts like
14,000,
500 years or something where native
people look at them and say,
that's the most intriguing animal on the
continent.
It's for one thing,
mammoths,
camels,
horses.
All these big charismatic animals are
dying out around us in the pleistocene
extinctions.
Somehow these little guys don't seem to
be perturbed by it.
They're surviving while all of these big
creatures,
these big impressive creatures are going
away.
And I think they also,
at least this is what I argue in the
book,
they had this sense that a coyote is
live by their widths.
And I think that provided them with a
model that they thought was valuable.
Because I think living successfully,
because you're smart,
you know,
is that's a trait that humans in any
age,
including ours right now,
uh,
could very well a follow and find to be
a,
uh,
an effective way to go about facing your
future.
So they see this animal is being
particularly smart,
particularly adaptable,
a survivor,
and because it was a social animal,
it has pups the pups don't know how to
fend for themselves in the world.
And coyotes have to teach the pups just
as humans do with their children.
How to become full grown coyotes and how
to survive that.
It seemed to have a lot of traits that
people found familiar.
And so at some point in time,
and who knows when it was,
I mean,
it could have been 10,000 years ago,
they converted into Indian people in the
West everywhere.
Coyotes range,
convert this animal into one of their
principle,
God's their principal deities and make
it this sacred creature.
I mean,
they have no reason to kill them or
harass them or anything.
And so instead they look at it as this
Avatar,
this stand in for humans.
In the world,
study it really closely and they proceed
to create this body of,
of literature.
It's our oldest literature from North
America,
uh,
in the form of oral stories that have
coyote as the central character,
but it's not,
it's not the little coyote that's
trotting through your camp.
It's a coyote man.
He's a character who stands on his hind
legs.
He has pointed nose and he has direct
ears and he has a tail,
but he's standing up and he personifies
all the traits,
both good and bad of human beings.
It's,
it's
so weird.
That was the way we look at coyotes
today is this new sense and this past,
and that's directly attributed to
agriculture,
right?
Directly attributed to us having
livestock anywhere near them,
deciding we want them out.
But if you look at the Museum of natural
history in Los Angeles,
when I was there,
I took a photo of it because it was so
weird.
I put on my instagram there,
the photo,
the,
the stuffed coyote that they have there.
They have all these different animals.
They have African animals,
they have gorillas,
chimpanzees,
all these different stuffed animals.
I just sort of give you a sense of what
they would look like with this mock
natural environment that coyote is
natural environment.
They show a porch and the coyote has a
cat in it's mouth.
I mean,
this is this,
this is this image right here.
That is my photo that I took from the
Museum of natural history.
It's like what?
Like that's the natural environment is a
porch with a cat in his mouth.
It's,
it's so bizarre.
But that's how human beings,
especially in and around La,
view them.
I know when I had my situation with the
chicken before I started reading your
book,
I thought about killing that coyote.
It was like,
I want to kill that fucker.
He killed my chicken.
I'm going to kill him.
Then I found out,
I believe I'm pretty sure that it was a
female because,
uh,
he,
this female kind of honey Dick my dog
into jumping the fence and efforting,
converting with her and that's how they
got the chickens because my dog's huge.
I have a massive.
And he knocked over this.
When chickens,
when they,
uh,
they,
they brewed.
Do you know about chickens brooding?
Do you know that?
My Dad had chickens in Louisiana.
So yeah,
I kind of,
uh,
you know,
hanging out with him when I would go
back and visit.
Uh,
I came to know a little bit about
chickens.
Well,
people don't know what happens is
chickens think that their eggs,
the only way the chickens have eggs
every day pretty much or sort of every
day,
every few days.
And when they have an egg,
a,
those eggs are non-viable.
That's one of the reasons why
vegetarians can eat chicken eggs and get
protein from them.
You're not hurting anybody.
They have the eggs,
whether or not there's a chicken there
are any or not.
They always have the egg and it has to
be fertilized by the rooster in order
for it to become a chicken.
I didn't figure that out,
so it was almost 40,
but my stupid head,
I was like,
oh,
the egg means there's a chicken and
there you just gotTa Cook it before it
becomes a chicken.
No stupid.
Anyway.
Um,
the chicken sometimes are convinced that
these non viable eggs will become
chicks.
And so they sit on them and they start
plucking their feathers out and it takes
the entire cycle that an egg would be
viable and become a chick for them to
get out of it.
The only way to stop them is to put them
on a perch and put them in a smaller
cage.
So we put them in a perch and the
smaller cage,
we separate them from the chicken coop
and the coyote had figured this out,
that this chicken was by itself and
convinced the massive to knock the cage
over because it was too small to knock
this coop over.
But the master is 140 pounds.
He's like,
I'll fucking
take care of.
He knocks the coop down that coyote says
thanks.
Grabs the chicken and then jumps and
hops the fence.
And I was talking to my neighbor about,
he's like,
Oh man,
I fucking hate coyotes.
I go,
do you like rats?
Because if you don't like rats,
you should thank the coyotes.
The reason why we're not infested with
rats,
I mean we're in the hills.
When you're in the hills,
out here in California,
there's rats and rodents everywhere,
but they're not,
and the reason why is because these
coyotes,
we make that mistake so often where we
think that we're smart and we're going
to eliminate one thing in this,
this system,
and it's gonna be fine.
Now.
All we have to do is take out this
coyote and everything will be great,
but no,
you're going to have a rat infestation
and that's one of the things that you
talked about in your book about farmers
who had chased off the coyotes and they
had rapid infestations and they were
praying for coyotes.
I mean this happens in a just over and
over and over again.
And so I think one of the reasons that
we tend to make endlessly make the same
mistake with animals like this is
because we don't try to spend any effort
to understand the ecological world
around us and to understand their role
in it in particular.
And you know what I mean?
I've been going around the country a lot
over the last eight months talking about
this book because obviously everybody is
dealing with them and some people are
brand new in dealing with them and they
were alarmed first of all that there's
this small wolf trotting down the street
or through their yard.
And then of course they immediately
here.
Well,
it's going to get your cat scan to get
your small dog.
It's got a level to grab your three year
old.
I mean,
you just saw the horror stories,
uh,
through kind of urban legend make the
rounds,
you know,
at a,
at an accelerated rate and sort of basic
good information about the animal
doesn't make the round very effectively
at all.
It's not fun.
No,
it's not fun.
But what you have to grapple with first
of all is you've got to start with a
position,
which I'll admit this is not the
American position to take.
It's the position that in this instance,
we have confronted a part of the natural
world that we are not able to control.
We can't control coyotes.
We met resistance basically as futile.
They're going to be among us no matter
what we do.
I mean,
you can certainly take out.
I,
you know,
coyotes are individuals and so if
there's a bad actor in the neighborhood
and very few of them,
by the way in the studies of coyotes in
urban settings are bad actors,
but occasionally there's one that starts
catching cats are a starts chasing dogs
or something.
I mean you can take that one out and
perhaps improve the situation,
but just blanket going after any coyote
you're afraid of something like your cat
might disappear is going to boomerang in
every instance because attempts to
persecute them as I try to point out
over and over and Coyote America result
in every case and more coyotes and and
it skews the populations so that what
you end up with are often youngsters,
teenagers,
that like human teenagers get in more
trouble than adults do.
So the thing that I keep trying to do,
and of course there's a group in
California and San Francisco called
project coyote that's been at this a
trying to help people understand how to
coexist but coexist with coyotes for the
last seven or eight years.
What you have to do is first of all,
accept the fact that,
okay,
resistance is futile.
These animals are here.
They know how to live in an urban
setting.
They know how to live in the hills
around me.
Now I've got to figure out how I live
with coyotes in my life.
And I mean,
the obvious thing is you don't let your
cats out in the morning to go hunt
songbirds.
You don't let your cats out at night.
I mean the coyotes are,
in most instances,
not attacking cats are small dogs
because they want to eat them.
They regard them as competitor predators
in their territory and so they're
attacking them because that's how they.
They see them,
but they do eat them,
right?
Well,
they,
they will eat them in some instances
when they're trying to provision a
litter of pups.
So the times when cats will be snatched
by coyotes and will disappear and you
don't see the cat again is often the
period from basically about now from
April through about July,
that's when they have their litters and
I mean it's sometimes hard to come up
with enough protein to raise five or six
little coyote pups.
And so occasionally a cat or a small dog
will be taken away.
But usually what happens with cats and
small dogs is that Kylie's attack them
and they just leave them there.
And I've told people for,
uh,
for most of this year,
I mean this is from my own experience
because I've lived in the urban
wildlands interface for almost all my
adult life out in the countryside away
from town.
Whenever you find your cat,
that's probably a coyote and its attack
the cat because it thinks it's a
competitor and it attacks,
it kills.
It leaves it.
If the animal disappears,
if your cat disappears and you never see
it again,
either that's happened in the time when
they're provisioning pups or if it
happens in the fall or the winter or the
early spring.
And your cat totally disappears.
It probably was a great horned owl that
got your cat.
I mean als pluck
cats and take them to their roost and
devour them.
And so your cat disappears.
Then you never see it again.
But what almost everybody does now that
we know,
we've got coyotes as hear coyotes
howling and the hills,
the neighbor had a cat disappeared.
Of course it was a coyote.
Coyote got it.
Yeah.
But it might not be a,
I would say in a pretty sizeable
percentage of cases.
It was actually a great horned owl that
got the cat and not a coyote.
There's a great video that I found
online that I put on my instagram of an
owl snatching some other raptor right
out of its nest.
Have you ever seen it?
I haven't seen it.
But uh,
it's someone that had like a trail cam,
a video up a black and white trail cam.
And you see the owl flying in the
distance or is it you see the eyes and
then you see it snap and the other bird
in the nest doesn't even know what
happened.
It had watched this.
Yeah,
it happened so fast.
So what first of all,
do you know what kind of animal that is?
That.
What would that bird is?
Can you tell by looking at it?
It looks like a hawk.
Have some fledgling.
Boom.
That's it.
I look at the other ones like what
happened?
What's going on?
Yeah,
that's a hawk of some kind.
Maybe a red tail and the fledgling.
Just the eyes and the distance are
amazing.
Look through these eyes.
Sneaking up.
Look at this.
Here it comes.
It's so funny that we think of that
thing is.
Oh the wise old owl.
Give a hoot.
Don't pollute.
Meanwhile,
those motherfuckers are as evil as it
gets.
Well they are definitely major predators
and they hear the stories about them in
New Mexico.
I mean there.
I've got friends who were sitting at a,
at an outdoor bar a couple of years ago
with a railing on it.
It was a late afternoon and a cat was
walking along the railing,
whether sitting there with their drinks,
shooting the shit,
and all of a sudden an al comes in and
in a flash plucks that cat off the
railing and the next thing they say is
the owl flying off to the cottonwood
trees over the creek with this cat
dangling from its.
Yeah,
while they're all sitting there with
their drinks,
poison in the air.
I was driving home one day and I saw
this hour,
we'll fly right above my head and I must
have apparently while I was driving,
it must have got this rabbit somewhere
close to it and I startled it so it's
flying off and decided to drop the
rabbit.
So we're like right in front of me in
the highway or the road.
Was this eviscerated rabbit?
No.
Big Rabbit too.
And I was in that.
That was one of the first years that I
lived here.
And I remember thinking,
Oh,
I gotta read.
I gotta recalibrate my idea when an owl
is getting.
Because it was just torn apart and it
was a big rabbit and I saw this.
I mean it was a big owl too,
so the whole thing was like,
Whoa,
this is a predator,
this isn't just a bird icon.
They and that's the way they killed two.
That's what they do with cats.
They eviscerate them,
they put a talent.
I'm basically into their ass and just
rip it all the way up,
all the way up to their sternum,
spilled their guts out.
Whew.
There's a wildlife near here and we
visited a couple of times and they have
owls there and you get to see them and
check them out up close like animals
that had been injured and things like
that.
And you just see the talents on those
suckers and just woof.
There's serious.
Yeah.
It's fascinating how we anthropomorphize
some of these animals and turn them into
these cutie pies.
You know,
like polar bears are selling Coca Cola
and Klondike bars and owls are selling
tootsie roll pops.
We evolved it just they're out there,
Jack and cats.
You know,
there's a video in Los Angeles and one
of the reasons why I wanted to ask you
about this is because I'd heard you say
before,
I think on Renell's podcast,
what you just said about cats and dogs,
that essentially they're there,
the coyotes,
think of them as competitive predators.
Yeah.
But there's a video in Los Angeles,
uh,
in Hollywood have a coyote eating a cat
on a lawn and a,
these people are in the car watching and
they're filming it and they're freaking
out.
Like,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
it's Kylie was just sitting there eating
that cat.
So you think that the reason why it's
eating that music just hungry maybe,
or is it,
is it an occasional meal that they think
of them as prey or is it primarily
because they're a bunch of different
factors or is it primarily because
they're competitive predators?
Well,
I think it's primarily because of that,
but I mean there are.
So,
you know,
there's coyotes are so individualistic.
Okay.
That's soccer hanging out right now.
Like,
hi,
how are you?
Wild animal walking by the car,
right in Los Angeles.
I mean,
just so bizarre that they're so
comfortable around people treat like a
little city streets.
It's thinking about walking across the
street,
don't know how to navigate the streets
like that too.
So strange.
How does it figure out how to make it
across the street?
You know,
there's a,
there's a biologist in Chicago who
argues that in rush hour traffic on the
interstate in Chicago,
9 million people there that he's seen
coyotes cross four lanes of the
interstate and stop in the median and
sit there and wait until the traffic
lightens up for the other four lanes and
then cross that way.
So this is,
uh,
the coyote goes and gets this cat that
apparently it had already killed before
he starts eating it.
So it's got it right there.
Yeah.
That thing at his feet.
His cat.
Yeah.
Well,
what I was going to say about that is
that yeah,
it's all stiff.
Yeah.
Well he's.
So what a strange animal.
You know.
So.
So two things I would observe about this
particular video is,
first of all,
you know,
everybody is making the assumption that
coyote killed the cat.
That cat may have been hit by a car and
the coyote founded in is scavenging it.
How about another stupid cat behind
them?
That's my friend right behind the low.
Why are you eating my friend?
The other thing I would say is that
they're so individualistic that
sometimes cats,
they develop.
A coyote is develop a yen for cats.
I could taste.
Yes,
they develop a taste for them and so I
mean,
there are examples.
There was a coyote pack in Seattle and
also one in Tucson that basically did
this very thing.
They.
They decided that cats,
we're going to be their target now.
Most coyotes,
you know,
that's not how they react to cats,
but cats do kill an unbelievable amount
of rodents and birds.
Yeah,
and people don't want to hear this of
course,
but the truth is that in all cities were
coyotes have spread,
which is literally everywhere now.
We have from the ornithologists a
decided record of numbers of nesting
songbirds going up dramatically as a
result of the appearance of coyotes.
Yeah.
There was a statistic that we quoted on
the podcast and it's something insane,
like 3 billion birds a year in North
America alone are killed by cats,
by house cats b with a b.
yeah.
When you tell that to people,
they're like,
there's no way,
but look,
these are biologists.
These are people that are actually
studying this,
and it blew them away.
I don't know how they studied it.
I don't.
Maybe you could enlighten me.
Well,
I don't either.
I mean,
one point 7 billion years annually,
seven birds in the continental us.
That is so crazy.
That's us.
That's not Canada.
It's not Mexico.
Continental us and I read a similar
study in natural history magazine a few
years ago about Great Britain.
Same,
same kind of thing.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't remember the figures anymore,
but yeah,
I mean cats,
you know,
they devastate bird populations and so
letting your cat Rome out through the
neighborhood.
And it seems like this very
compassionate thing to do.
You know,
fluffy wants to be out,
fluffy needs some space to roam,
but you're releasing an extremely
effective Predator into the world.
And that's the results of it and when
coyotes have shown up in town,
it's suddenly getting a lot harder to
make a living as a bird killing cats.
And so we're,
we're getting a sharp uptick now in
songbirds.
Yeah,
it's interesting how it all just cycles
and I'll just make sense and I'll figure
it out at all.
Seeks its own level.
I'm.
One of the things that I've found
hilarious was we were talking on is a
podcast about a group that approached
you and they were doing a documentary on
saving the coyote.
Yes.
And it was a,
a couple of women,
uh,
who,
were pretty fresh in into the southwest
and Santa Fe.
They hadn't been in town for very long
and they were interested in doing a
documentary to save
the Coyote and uh,
you know,
so I mean there's a way to approach
doing something like that.
Uh,
I mean you could say,
okay,
so I want wildlife services to stop
killing 80,000 of them a year on behalf
of agriculture.
Uh,
but what these women didn't seem to
quite have a handle on was that coyotes
don't need our help in saving
themselves.
They're perfectly capable of doing it.
And so,
uh,
this is not an animal you have to worry
about,
for example,
going on the endangered species list.
Uh,
and that's not gonna happen as one of
the people who blurbed my book.
In fact,
it was bill mckibben,
the nature writer.
Now that I think about it,
one of the things he said was that,
uh,
in his blurb was that a biologist wants
told him that when the last human dies
on earth,
a coyote will be sitting on that humans
grave howling at the moon.
I've always loved that thought because
of course it's a,
it's an indication of how,
what great survivors they are.
Well,
you are starting to see a resurgence of
wolves in Europe.
And,
uh,
there was actually an article recently
published in Paris about it were,
uh,
I guess the mayor of Paris was telling
people not to be alarmed because they
only look for four legged pray and
people shouldn't be worried about these
wolves.
But the idea of these animals like
intermingling with our,
with our civilization,
you know,
we,
we have decided,
we put some hardscape down,
put up some houses,
and we'll go,
this is our stuff.
You got to stay out and they don't
recognize these boundaries and now
you're slowly starting to see these
animals creep back in,
in Paris,
France,
in Paris.
That's right.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
you know,
I think when we moved into cities 5,000
years ago,
one of the things we thought we were
getting away from,
by living in cities was predators.
Yeah.
And the most part we have.
Most
part we have.
I mean,
we don't have,
you know,
at least not so far.
We don't have lepers in patrolling the
alleys and,
and,
uh,
Denver.
But I,
you know,
I'm intrigued by one of the stories I
uncovered in the book,
which is an argument that I make is
based on the work of a graduate student
I knew at the University of Montana,
his name is John Hall and he was doing a
dissertation in history on a,
what he was calling the great dog war in
the 19th century and what it was all
about.
And the more I dug into it,
I realized this is one of the
explanations for why you don't see
accounts of coyotes in cities much.
Uh,
even in,
in La.
I mean the first accounts I've seen of
Katie's in La for instance,
during the 19 twenties,
but it's because in the 19th century,
until about the 18 seventies,
we let dogs our own pets and packs of
feral dogs roam through American cities
at will.
And so every city in the United States
had a large population of feral and sort
of loosely owned dogs roaming around our
city scapes.
Pharaoh,
meaning they were totally wild,
or people would feed them and people
would feed them.
I mean,
they were just basically stray dogs that
would roam the city.
They would find things to scavenge
behind restaurants and behind the houses
and they would knock over people's
garbage and.
But in the.
This happened in,
I think in the late 18,
40 [inaudible] Boston had an epidemic
one year of rabies attacks from these
kinds of wild dogs in the city and so
Boston began to institute what became
our modern system of dog catchers,
dog pound's leash laws,
doc control,
and it was at the Moma when the Boston
model began to spread to Philadelphia,
to New York,
eventually to New Orleans,
eventually to the cities in California,
and we sort of instituted this new model
of,
okay,
a dog is properly meant to be in an
enclosed yard on a leash when it's with
its owner is supposed to be running
through the streets with packs of other
dogs scavenging a garbage and stuff.
When we did that,
what that in effect did was to open up
the niche in American cities for wild
canids and the wild Canaan that was able
to take advantage of it was the coyote
that provided them the opening that
hadn't been there before because a
coyote wandering into a city and the 18
sixties or 18 thirties would end up
being,
of course assaulted by dogs.
Suddenly all the dogs were put up and
that opened up the cities to the arrival
of coyotes in our midst.
Wow.
Just the interface between human beings
and the wild and our interaction with
the wild and then to start our ability
or inability to manipulate it.
It's just so fascinating to me.
And one of the things that I wanted to
talk to you about is what they're trying
to do right now,
uh,
in I guess it's Wyoming and parts of
Montana,
this,
uh,
American Serengeti Project.
Now we please explain that.
Well,
uh,
so this,
this other book that we've,
we've talked about some of mine that has
been out now just about a year.
It came out,
uh,
last,
last March of 2016.
Um,
that's a book,
American Serengeti is a book that's
about the story of the Great Plains and
the fact that we had up until about a
hundred and 25 or 130 years ago in North
America,
one of the what was widely regarded
around the globe as one of the great
wildlife spectacles of,
of the world.
And these enormous herds of bison have a
reemerging wildhorse bands of
pronghorns,
maybe 15,
$18 million pronghorns,
uh,
not quite as many as bison,
but almost as many a half million gray
wolves that were their predators.
Of course,
coyotes playing the role of Jackals,
a grizzly bears that roamed,
I mean,
the original range of the grizzly bear
was actually out on the plains.
They were all the way out into Kansas
and into Nebraska.
And I mean everybody saw the movie
revenant of course.
Uh,
which the filmmaker said in the rocky
mountains.
But that was based on an actual event
that happened in history.
A guy named Hugh glass getting mauled by
a grizzly that happened in South Dakota
though,
not up in the mountains because the
grizzlies were out on the plains in this
version of the Serengeti that prevailed
a 150 years ago.
But we ended up basically a wiping all
those animals out.
I mean,
we,
we wiped out probably as many as 30
million bison through the 19th century.
Almost all.
We got the prom horns down from 15
million to about 13,000.
Uh,
we drove the elk off the great plains.
That was their primary range was the
planes.
We drove them off and up into the
mountains.
Did the same thing with the grizzlies.
So we basically reduced this,
this American Serengeti,
which Africa didn't do with its
Serengeti or it's [inaudible] or it's
veiled.
It preserved all.
It's great animals,
but we destroyed hours and ended up not
ever successfully creating any kind of
wildlife preserve to sort of save at
least a part of it.
I mean,
we got yellowstone,
but of course yellowstone is said in the
rocky mountains.
And so what this American prairie
reserve is about now,
it's based in Bozeman,
Montana.
It's only about a dozen years old,
but it's been pretty wildly successful
in trying to do this.
It's had the imagination.
This group of people has had the
imagination to try to recreate this
American Serengeti that we are.
Our government in our state craft never
did preserve
forests and so what they've got in mind
in central Montana is taking a couple of
large pieces of of existing public
lands.
One is the Missouri River Breaks
National Monument that Bill Clinton
created a all along the Missouri River
and then just downstream of it still
along the Missouri River is the Charles
m russell national wildlife refuge.
And together those two public lands that
are along the Missouri River and mostly
on the South Bank of the Missouri River
in central Montana,
make up about one point six,
one point 7 million acres.
And what American prairie reserve is
trying to do is to,
as they come up for sale,
to acquire the private ranches on the
north side of the river,
with the idea of ultimately creating a,
a preserved that's going to be maybe as
big as twice the size of yellowstone
yellowstone's,
a little more than 2 million acres and
American prairie reserve is shooting for
a preserve that would be something like
4 million acres with the idea of
recreating this American Serengeti,
of repopulating it with Bison pronghorns
with elk,
with big horn sheep,
with mule deer.
All the animals that were there.
And then because they're a private
entity and they,
it's not the fish and wildlife service,
so they can't on their own merits,
reintroduce wolves or grizzly bears.
Just sort of sitting back and hoping and
letting wolves come out of the nearby
rockies and grizzlies,
which every spring now are coming out of
the,
uh,
the rocky mountain front and Montana and
getting out sometimes as much as 100
miles out into the plains.
What the American prairie reserve wants
to happen is for these animals to get
all the way out to this preserve,
find this,
recreated American Serengeti with all
the animals that were there and give us
in our own time and the 21st century
this chance to not just read about this
in history are maybe see some version of
it on a late night old western movie,
but actually to experience it ourselves
now,
how are they going to reintroduce these
animals and where they going to get them
from?
Well,
I mean,
getting the Bison is not too difficult
because their surplus bison,
I'm pretty much around,
uh,
most of the West.
I mean we've got a larger bison
population in North America right now
than we've had since the 18 nineties.
More than 300,000 of them.
So it's fairly easy to come up with
bison.
Pronghorns are already there.
Uh,
and so all you have to do is just sort
of make conditions,
uh,
beneficial for their herds to grow.
Same thing with mule deer,
with elk,
with big horns,
they're going that they'll have to
reintroduce big horns.
But that was an original range.
There were big horns out on the,
in the badlands of the great plains.
And then,
as I said,
they can't deliberately on their own
reintroduce gray wolves or grizzly
bears,
but they're a idea is that if wolves and
grizzlies get there,
then they're welcome.
And,
and the idea is they probably wants this
preserve exists with all these grazing
animals that the wolves and the bears
will,
will find it.
Wow.
That's so fascinating.
And now do they have a timeline?
They're trying to accomplish this in,
you know,
it's a,
as I said,
they've been around for about 10 or 12
years now.
I mean they've raised more than $130
million dollars and they've got major
donors on both the coasts along with
lots of,
you know,
just people like you and me who give
them 10 and $15 or $25.
I've got lots of friends who,
once I sort of alerted them to this,
who have joined American prairie reserve
and our,
and our donors,
small donors.
Um,
the timeline is basically whenever they
can make it happen.
I mean,
the,
there's some,
a considerable resistance from the
ranching community,
uh,
not only in Montana but kind of across
the West because ranchers don't want to
see Bison and especially by sudden
predators replace cattle herds,
so there's kind of an ideological
opposition on the part of,
of ranching people,
but,
and that's two fold,
right?
It's one because of the food that the
bison would eat because the battle for
resources,
but also because of brucellosis.
Well,
brucellosis of courses,
especially in Montana and they explained
to people that's disease disease,
it's a disease that,
uh,
that bison and elk have and that if
cattle get it,
their beef cannot be sold,
uh,
in North American markets,
all beef that's sold in our supermarkets
has to be brucellosis free.
And how do they determine that?
Do they have to test each individual
animal when they swatted them?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean they would,
if there was a real threat about it.
The truth is there has never been an
instance in the wild of either a bison
or an elk transferring brucellosis to
cattle.
How would they transfer it to the FDA at
the same food?
Now they basically,
it comes through a largely from
afterbirth whenever they,
uh,
whenever a bison a cow for example,
that has brucellosis gives birth.
If cattle come through the area a say
within a few days and graze the same
grass where after birth,
uh,
has been dropped from a brucellosis
infected bison,
then the theory is that a cow could get
the disease.
It's been made to happen that way.
And laboratories,
we have no record of it ever having
happened in the wild.
When now when they made it happen in
laboratories,
did they force feed the cows?
I don't think so.
I mean,
but I have to say that I've,
I've not read the study so I'm not quite
sure how they,
how they pulled it off,
but they did.
They did make the transfer happen in a
laboratory setting.
Uh,
what's been bizarre about the whole
brucellosis thing is that elk are
infected with brucellosis far more than
by center,
but the ranching community doesn't seem
to be concerned about elk bison that
they don't want.
And why is that?
Well,
I mean,
part of it,
it seems to me almost dates back to the
19th century when we destroyed the,
uh,
original American Serengeti and killed
all these bison and converted the great
plains into largely a ranching country
with cattle.
I mean in the idea has been from the
ranching community ever since that bison
are a direct threat to the existing
ranching community that if you get too
many people and namor herd of Bison,
uh,
you know,
and I'm not sure I can track the logic
of their arguments,
but it somehow seems to lead in that
direction.
They don't like people introducing bison
into the middle of a ranching setting,
particularly what they don't seem to
like is someone with an old Montana
ranch of 40 or 50,000 acres selling that
ranch.
So somebody like American prairie
reserve,
which clearly is going to introduce
wildlife on it and remove it from as an
active sort of livestock ranching.
A economic enterprise is interesting
because it's a superior meet to bisons
better meat and that's a better meat,
better meat for you,
much less fat in it.
It's,
yeah,
it's.
So this is a,
I think the most exciting conservation
project that's out in the West in our
time.
Uh,
this is something that we didn't get and
a lot of people don't know that.
That's kind of why I wrote this American
Serengeti Book because I wanted people
to understand that only 120 530 years
ago we had the equivalent of the Masai
Mara in places like Nebraska and South
Dakota and eastern Montana and wow.
And we destroyed it.
And just like that and just the space of
a few decades,
we completely wiped it out.
And as I said a minute ago,
what seems to me to be the largest
destruction wholesale destruction of
wildlife discoverable in modern history.
And so right now the American prairie
reserve is just,
they're just taking that land and buying
it up and they haven't started this
project at now.
They have started the project.
Yeah,
it certainly exists and I've got a map
of it in the,
in the book and American Serengeti and
they've reintroduced animals already.
They have reintroduced animals.
They're trying to come up with 12,000.
So they have an instagram page.
Look at that.
Yeah.
American prairie reserve as an instagram
page.
Absolutely.
Only 1700 followers.
How dare they.
So click on that picture of the bison
down there.
Below that,
below that Jamie lower right hand
corner.
There you go.
Lower right hand corner.
Yeah,
yeah.
Look at that.
Oh Wow.
Interesting.
So,
um,
there's a lot of bias in there roaming
around and this is land that they
occupied.
And so these bison have a essentially
very few predators and they're just
wandering around and they're going to
repopulate.
We've got to repopulate.
And uh,
so one of the things that,
uh,
American prairie reserve does when they
acquire these ranches is that they
remove the fencing from.
I mean they've been fenced of course to
create pastures for bison,
but they removed or for cattle,
but they removed the fencing in order to
let bison roam freely.
And of course,
the idea is you ultimately have to have
the predators back.
You're not going to have a complete
ecosystem unless you have the predators
there as well.
That is really tricky,
right?
Because they're not allowed to
reintroduce grizzly bears.
They are not allowed to as a private
organization,
oh,
the fish and wildlife service would have
to do this and fish and wildlife service
doesn't actually,
even the public lands that are there are
not managed by the US fish and wildlife
service.
And good luck getting cooperation from
people in Montana.
There's still stinging from the wolves
being introduced into yellowstone and
the decimation of the elk population and
all the other livestock issues that
they've had there.
Yeah.
So,
so they argue,
at least when I was at the last few
years I was in Montana,
and this was about 10 years after the
wolves had been recovered.
We had about 1700 gray wolves in Montana
or in the northern rockies actually,
uh,
by about 2012 or so.
And uh,
so the hunters in Montana were up in
arms sort of the way these white tail
hunters in South Carolina now are up in
arms over coyotes.
The hunters of Montana were up in arms
because it wasn't so easy to get an elk
anymore and they blamed it all on
wolves.
And someone from the University of
Montana did a study of a particular herd
that had been singled out as one that
was just being harassed by wolves and
you know,
and it was impossible to kill bull there
anymore and concluded that actually most
of the production that was taking place
on that elk herd was from mountain lions
and not the wolves that had been
reintroduced,
but it's become the for the hunting
community,
the sport hunting community,
which has had,
of course a century now of getting to
hunt elk and white tails and deer and
everything else
without competition from predators.
This has become kind of the new excuse
of why I didn't get my elk this year.
Right.
That makes sense.
And then also,
uh,
I think it's super important that the
hunting community step back and
understand that these animals are
supposed to be preyed upon by wolves and
that without them you're going to get to
these enormous overpopulation,
which had happened in that hundred year
period when we were reintroducing elk
with no predators.
They develop diseases and Montana has no
shortage of ALC.
I was there this summer and we drove by
this house and we had to pull over and
luckily I had binoculars in my car and I
gave him my kids and the first time they
saw elk,
there was a hundred elk on this lawn,
hundred there were all over the place
and uh,
one of the women who lives there was
explained to us that they had wolves
come through just a couple of nights
before and it was really exciting and
everybody's looking out the window and I
think if you live there,
if you're a person who was an elk
hunter,
especially if you're a lazy one,
I get where you could see that that
would be something you would complain
about,
but think the ELC adapt,
you know,
they figured it out.
They don't call as much and people are
complaining about that.
You don't hear the bugling as much,
but that bugling was probably a little
unnatural.
They get a little too cocky that they
could just scream and yell whenever they
were breeding.
You know,
what they got preyed upon.
Right.
Well,
you know,
what we have to remember is that we are
newcomers to North America.
This is a very old place and wolves and
coyotes and mountain lions have been
part of the ecological equation here
with all of these animals that we like
to hunt with pronghorns,
with elk,
with mule deer.
I mean this is,
they've been evolving with one another
for hundreds of thousands of years.
I mean pronghorns,
I talk about this and the American
Serengeti book,
pronghorn females always have two fonts.
They basically have little litters of
two and the reason they have to is
because coyotes prey on pronghorn funds.
And so you basically have an heir and a
spare and the spares,
the one that you assumed the coyotes are
going to get.
Wow.
So,
and they evolve disability,
you know,
hundreds of thousands of years ago.
So I think part of it is just coming to
terms with the fact that we're,
we're brand new here and it's gonna take
awhile for us to actually truly become
Americans in an ecological sense.
In one way to do it is to think in terms
of these long patterns that extinct
stand back through time.
I want to talk to you about your paper
on Bison is called Bison diplomacy and
bison ecology or is it the opposite?
Bison ecology.
Diplomacy.
Yeah.
And what you were saying was,
and this I found incredibly fascinating
was that when we came along,
when the mark,
I say we obviously my grandparents were
immigrants,
wasn't me,
but when Europeans,
when you know,
people that we consider Americans now
came along a few hundred years ago,
and then when they started doing the
market hunting and killing off all the
bison,
well,
we had done was something that the
native Americans were already on their
way to doing.
Well,
I mean,
so let me,
let me sort of offer a revision of that.
Okay.
Um,
native people and Bison,
uh,
had coexisted in that had been going on
for eight or 9,000 years with,
with the,
the modern bison.
I mean,
if you track it back to,
you know,
the large Pleistocene Bison,
bison,
antiquity and bison latter fronds,
the big Longhorn Bison Longhorn.
Bison,
what is that?
Oh,
amy.
Yeah.
It was by some Latin frons.
It's called Lana frons.
Frons.
Yeah.
And so it's a long horn bison.
And then there was a slightly smaller
one that existed farther into into our
own time or the bison that we experience
any of these pure.
Well,
some herds are.
Wow.
Look at that thing.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's bias.
A lot of fraud.
I'm sure you're aware of the scrub bowls
like particularly in Australia with
these animals get free and they become
feral domestic cows change their
characteristics,
look at the size of that thing.
So what the Lord.
Yeah.
So what that graphic shows is the
contemporary are bison over on the right
side of the graphic and you can see how
much smaller it is than the animals that
were here during the pleistocene by some
latter fronds as the animal over on the
far left.
And Bison antiquity is one of these in
the middle.
It's probably the very middle one right
there.
These animals were hunted by early human
hunters here too when the plot,
because they arrived before the
pleistocene produced that extinction
scenario.
So they hunted these,
these large forms of Bison,
but about 8,000 years ago,
Bison,
the large ones having become extinct.
Bison sort of evolved into this smaller.
I mean some people actually refer to the
Modern Boston as a dwarf complex
compared to these older ones.
And so what I argue,
and I've got a chapter on this and
American Serengeti to Sorta my most
recent take on this bison ecology bison
diplomacy piece,
which came out in a very fancy,
a journal Academic Journal,
but 25 years ago now.
But what I argue is that that hunt had
been going on for 8,000 years and
probably the reason that bison never
that Indians never hunted them to
extinction is because bison were
actually better adapted to the
grasslands than people were.
So they were more successful as a
grassland species than humans were.
Until we get the introduction from the
European arrival of a couple of things
that change the equation.
One is the reintroduction of the horse
to North America,
which native people in the west quickly
take up and gives him a bill.
An ability to hunt bison far more
efficiently and to become just as well
adapted to life on the grasslands as the
as the bison was.
But the other thing that changes the
equation is the market and the
introduction of the market economy.
And so what that article actually argued
and what my chapter in American
Serengeti argues to I haven't changed my
mind over the last 25 years about this,
is that the market became a force for
native people just as it did for people
all around the world in Africa and India
and everywhere else that they found
difficult to resist.
And one of the primary reasons they
found it difficult to resist was because
if you were hunting with flint
arrowheads,
your best arrowhead maker could maybe
produce 15 of them through hard labor in
a day.
But you could go out and kill a bison
and have your wife Tan.
It's pelt and make a robe.
A softly tan robe out of it.
And you could trade that to a white
trader from the Hudson's Bay company or
the American fur company and they would
give you a hundred and 50 steel
arrowheads that were far better than the
flint ones that took your best arrow
maker a day to produce and you could get
150 of them for the work of 30 minutes
going out and shooting a bison.
And of course your wife had to spend a
week working on the pill.
But basically the European market had so
many labor saving technologies,
steel arrowheads,
steel knives,
steel hatchets,
a firearms that it became almost
impossible for Indian people to resist
trading for those things.
I mean,
and if you didn't trade for them and the
tribe down the river did,
then they suddenly had guns and you
didn't.
And so you were going to be out competed
by your neighbors.
And so in effect,
what happened was at the lure of the
goods of the industrial world in the
market economy,
drew Indian people into the market hunt
so that by the 18,
20,
18 thirties,
18 forties,
they were still killing buffalo.
In order to provide meat for the family
and to provide,
you know,
a hides to make a teepee and all that,
but they were killing and additional
percentage of animals to trade to the
European market.
And so they became actors in the market
economy that was basically wiping all
these animals out.
So he also was the reintroduction of the
horse as well,
right?
Because I was in before that they were
hunting these animals on foot and they
were far less effective.
Yeah.
And they,
they're,
they're beasts of burden was the dog.
And so you couldn't travel nearly as
far,
obviously by using dog propelled
locomotion as you could horses,
uh,
and you couldn't carry the kind of
burdens,
that kind of goods that you could carry
on dogs that you could with horses.
And so the transformation from being a
dog propelled people to being a horse.
Propel people was a,
it was a revolution in their lives.
I mean,
in one of the things that happened as a
result of it,
what was it?
There were people all around the borders
of the plains,
many of whom were agriculturalists,
who are farmers who ended up especially
their young men,
ended up abandoning farming because they
realized that the potential for rising
and status and for creating a better
life was much higher if you match it up
on a horse and rode out into the plains
and hunted buffalo.
And so,
I mean,
there were entire groups like the crows
had been relatives of demand.
Dan's in the adult says,
and had been agriculturalists and that
entire group of people,
uh,
ended up abandoning farming,
mattered up on horses,
rode down to the planes,
become buffalo hunters.
I mean,
during the period from basically about
17,
20,
when a lot of the people in the west
began to acquire horses.
And the,
the,
what?
Spread horses,
as I mentioned earlier in our
conversation,
was basically in 16,
80,
the Pueblo Indians down in New Mexico
rose up against the Spanish colonists
and drove them out of New Mexico.
And in the process,
they captured all their herds of
livestock.
They captured their goats,
their sheep and their horse hurts and
some animals.
Some of the horses got loose and it's
sort of the origin,
at least one of the origins of the wild
horses that spread across the West.
But the Pueblo Indians trade the sheep
and the goats to the people who become
the Navajos.
They become herders of goats and sheep
and they start trading the horses,
which they have now in great surplus
that they've liberated from the
Spaniards up the mountains from one
tribe to another,
to the youth,
to the shoney's,
to the Nez perce,
to the black feet,
uh,
to the essential ones.
And then on out on the plains.
And so from a 16,
80 through about 17,
20 or 70 slash 30,
just about everybody in the west ends up
getting horses.
And you have to have the culture with it
too.
I mean,
you can't just hand the animal over to
somebody.
And there's a famous story where the
first horse that the blackfeet say they
offer it buffalo meat to eight.
And somebody has to say as a Kalispell,
Indiana,
who's riding the horses?
No,
no,
not buffalo meat.
It eats grass.
It grazes on.
You have to feed it grass.
And they have to be shown how to take
care of horses and how to Gal stallions
and how to ride them and how to break
them and the whole bit.
So there's a culture that goes with it,
but once they acquire them,
and this period that only lasts for
about 200 years of the famous horse
mounted buffalo hunting plains Indian
emerges,
that lifestyle becomes,
which is kind of a backward step really
in anthropological terms.
You assume that,
you know,
you go from hunting to be in farmer and
you go from farmer to being a city
dweller.
This is a step going back the other way,
but it proved to be so compelling to so
many people,
as I said earlier,
especially young men who often in these
farming communities didn't have much
opportunity for upward mobility,
but you can mount up on that horse and
ride out and become buffalo hunter and
men,
you know,
the world was your oyster.
Wow.
So was essentially the influence of the
Europeans coming here and offering up
the market and creating this environment
where they were.
It was really profitable now and so.
And it became kind of something that
native people almost couldn't escape.
You couldn't get away from it because I
mean,
there were some groups that said,
okay,
we're not going to participate in this,
you know,
but that immediately disadvantaged them
compared to the group right down the
river.
And so people who didn't participate,
we're pretty quickly overrun by the
people who became fully engaged in the
horse hunt and the market hunt.
And I mean there are instances where,
I mean like the,
the Su and people,
you know,
in the movies,
the Lakotas,
I mean they basically march across the
northern West,
like pac man,
once they acquire horses,
they come out of Minnesota and out of
the woodlands and March across the West,
gobbling up one tribe after another and
taking away their buffalo hunting
territory.
I mean,
they're still doing it down to the time,
the battle of the little big horn.
That's why the crow's feet on the side
of the United States at the battle of
little big horn is because the lakotas
are seizing their countryside.
The Go Lakota is what they call
themselves and other native Americans
call them the Su,
which means enemy and the word that
we've used in history as the Sioux,
but I mean I'm on the southern plains.
The Comanche's did basically the same
thing.
They created this empire that was really
on a par and able to compete with the
Spanish empire,
with the Republic of Texas and even for
awhile against the United States and
they created it around this.
This horse propelled bison hunt that
provided goods for the market economy.
Now you were talking about steel
arrowheads.
Did they,
or when did they start using firearms?
While I started using firearms?
I mean,
I was,
uh,
an early trade item and it was usually
in the very beginning of,
of contact between Europeans and native
people.
A firearm was,
you know,
maybe a couple of them were given to the
headman to the leaders of particular
tribe as a status item.
One time I was an editor on a forum
anthropological journal called Ethno
history.
And my task as a,
an editor,
I was a cyst,
associate editor or something.
But my task was to read the the incoming
manuscripts that were submitted for
publication,
and one of the ones I read,
I've never forgotten.
This was an account by a trader in South
America who was turning his trading post
over to a newly arriving trader.
I think they were Portuguese.
And so this trader who had experience in
the area was queried by the new guy,
said,
so how do I get the Indians to trade
with me?
And the guy who had been on the scene
for a while said nothing to it,
ride out 15 or 20 miles into the
wilderness and take a steel ax
and
suspended from a rope from the branch of
a tree
and then leave.
And then
two weeks,
three weeks later go back.
And this guy,
this new trader,
did exactly that.
And he went back two weeks later to the
spot that's clearing in the forest and
the Amazonian forest where he had tied
this double bladed steel ax.
And there were hundreds of native people
gathered around the spot wanting more of
these objects were or have these access.
Because steel.
I mean there's a famous.
When Captain Cook first puts off the
coast,
off the Waimea coast of Hawaii and the
Hawaiian people paddle there,
outriggers out and climb on board his
ships and immediately start pulling all
the nails out of the planking on the
ship and diving off into the water with
the nails because they want metal.
They realized this is such an advantage
over the technology that they have.
And so I mean,
they're willing to trade what?
What do you want for an x?
Wow,
what do you want for a box of nails?
So they just let the people know that
the acs was a thing hanging from a tree,
leaving for awhile,
let him play with it and go back.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's,
that's a mindblower.
So that's how how native people kind of
all over the world who hadn't progressed
to the iron revolution,
to the Iron Age were seduced into the
market economy,
is that they were offered items that
were so compelling.
And as I have said a couple of times
now,
if you.
If you didn't participate in it,
you kind of within a decade you were
disadvantaged because everybody around
you was going to end up doing it and so
you got caught up in it and so that's
how.
That's how what I was arguing in Bison
ecology and vice and diplomacy m and and
I,
I the argument is slightly revised and
American Serengeti,
but it's the same argument and it's
become the prevailing argument about
what happened to bison and the 19th
century is we used to think that okay,
they were still 100 million of them by
the end of the civil war and then guys
go out with rifles in the space of 20
years.
They shoot them all down and that's the
end of it for their tongues and further
hides,
but what the story actually is is a much
more believable and real story that it
has to do with the introduction of
horses which drink water and graze grass
and so that reduces the carrying
capacity for Bison wants.
There are two or 3 million horses out on
the plains.
There can't be as many bison anymore.
It happens because there is a climate
downturn in the 1840 [inaudible] for
about 15 years.
There's a drought and that reduces the
carrying capacity for Bison.
So climate plays a role.
Um,
we know that diseases like anthrax and
ultimately brucellosis get among the
buffalo herds and those diseases
probably got among the buffalo herds
because oxygen and other animals on the
overland trails took these European
exotic diseases out among the bison
herds and infected them with disease.
And then there is no question that the
way the market worked it was mean.
And there's,
of course no regulation of it.
This is before we ever regulate,
you know,
we have any environmental regulations.
It's just a free for all capitalist
world also.
No refrigeration,
the refrigeration.
So you had to kill it and eat it within
a certain time period.
So the,
you can find a mate and that and that
dry climate you can dry it and preserve
some of it.
But yeah,
there's no refrigeration.
So,
you know,
and I mean there's no refrigeration
thing really plays a role in the
[inaudible],
the famous buffalo jumps that happen in
the West because you know,
you couldn't control how many animals
were going to go off those jumps.
And so if you wanted to run 10 off in
order to provide you with buffalo for
the next month and a half,
your tribe of 125 with Buffalo Buffalo
jumps.
Been running them off cliffs running off
cliffs.
Yeah.
And you wanted to run off 10 and instead
you got into a herd of,
you know,
1300,
1300 and they all went off and it even
became this thing.
I mean we know about these buffalo jumps
that people regard.
Indian people regarded this as a
stratagem that you don't want to let
surviving buffalo go out onto the plains
and inform other buffalo that there's
this thing called a jump that you want
to avoid.
And so that they end up wanting to make
sure that they get every single animal
that you're driving so that you don't
have buffalo go off and tell other
buffalo how this works.
But it's going to sound crazy,
but it makes you wonder if it was
ignorance on their part that the,
these animals could communicate like
that or if they had some sort of an
intuition about how instincts and how,
how certain fears that animals had were
developed.
Well,
I think,
you know,
and I,
I spent some time talking about this and
the Buffalo Chapter in American
Serengeti,
uh,
it has to do with what we would call
native science,
what you mentioned at the last there
that they do understand and they've
probably seen examples of,
you know,
an animal learning very quickly how to
avoid a trap.
But it also has to do with the cause
effect explanation that they have for
how the world works and the,
they don't have this kind of,
you know,
Western explanation for this is a cause
and this is an effect they have on a
cause effect relationship to be sure.
But it explains the world in a different
way.
And Indian people pretty,
pretty generally believed that bison
were a people that they were a family of
animals and they had families that were
very similar to the families at any and
people had and they had a controlling
master animal,
sort of a buffalo master who you had to
appeal to to get the animals to give
themselves up to humans for the good of
humanity.
And so the idea was that you had this
kind of,
um,
you know,
a theory or tie to these animals.
It was a tie that we would explain.
Now looking back on it,
we would say,
okay,
it's a religious thing.
This was some sort of spiritual kind of
understanding of how people and animals
interacted with one another.
But it was informed a little bit by kind
of native scientific observation too.
And I think in particular this one where
the argument was,
and it's from what I've read,
it's been,
it was pretty widespread that if you did
a buffalo jump,
you needed to kill all the animals that
went off the jump.
You couldn't let any of them get away.
I think that probably was more in the
line of kind of native science because
they maybe had observed.
They're being instances where an animal
that had gone off a jump and had
survived.
The next time you encountered that
animal.
It might be particularly marked with a
white patch on a hip or something and a
few months later you saw that particular
animal and another group of Bison and
when you try to do a jump,
it led that hurt off in a different
direction.
And so I think there was kind of native
science in that.
But the.
You know,
where we got to and talking about this
was no refrigeration.
So if you ran 1300 of them off and it's
August,
then all you're going to get to do and
you've got a group of 125 people.
All you're going to get to do is to
basically take the best pieces off about
25 or 30 animals and you're going to
lose the rest of it.
Because you can't preserve the meat of
all those animals.
So they find these sites where they'd
just be masked carcasses or mass bones.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
There's a site in Texas,
it's called a bonfire shelter site,
and the reason it's called that
anthropologists gave it.
There are archeologists gave it.
This name is because there was a bison
jump that was so big there.
We think about 10,000 years ago during
the folsom period that and so many
animals went off that jump and only a
few of them could be harvested by the
people who did the jump that that big
mass of animals sat there and basically
over two or three weeks of time burst
into spontaneous combustion and scorched
the cliff that they had gone off of.
And so when whites first saw it,
they thought somebody has built a giant
bonfire at the of that cliff.
Look at that.
It's strict a hundred feet up the side
of the cliff.
Now,
what archeologists realized about it
when they begin investigating it was
that it had been a huge mass of bison,
driven off a cliff that had burst in hot
weather and the spontaneous combustion
and probably burned for four or five
days.
How does that happen?
How did they,
how do they burst into flames?
Well,
I mean in hot weather with that much
decay and fermentation of all the juices
that are in intestines and stomach,
you basically create a condition where
you've got flammable chemistry.
That
lights put what causes the ignition?
You know,
who knows?
I mean,
I think it's the explanation I've read
is spontaneous,
but you know,
somebody may have walked over with a
torch and tossed it onto the pile of
animals and burn them.
Wow.
Thousands of animals.
Yeah.
Thousands of them.
You know,
it's interesting where you're talking
about with.
I'm explaining this idea that if one of
them survived that they would inform the
other ones.
There was a study that was done recently
on mice,
and this is a direct genetic study,
so it might not be totally related,
but it might be in some ways they took
these mice and they spray to citrus
smell in their cage,
and then when they smelled the citrus
smell,
they shocked them.
They shock their feet.
They had the bottom floor of the cage
was electrically charged,
and every time they sprayed that citrus
smell,
they would give them a zap.
Then their ancestors who had never
experienced this before,
they did the same thing to them,
just sprayed the citrus smell.
And they had a physical reaction,
a heightened sense of danger,
fear,
you know,
they,
they realized that a shock was coming
just by the smell that citrus,
they were terrified of it.
Yeah.
It makes sense that instincts are passed
on.
Well,
it does.
I mean,
we,
we've sort of concluded from studies
that have been done primarily in Italy,
uh,
over,
studying families through the
generations and Italy that
descendants of a particular group of
people will preserve evidence in their
jeans sometimes four,
five,
six generations down.
A timeline of an ancestor who went
through a famine or a starving time,
and so that famine would produce a
physiological effect on the body and
that would be passed down so that
geneticists could discover effects of it
several generations down the timeline.
So it's sort of similar to what you're
describing with,
with mice and think that's probably,
you know,
we just said we haven't studied,
at least I'm not aware that there had
been a lot of studies of this kind of
thing,
but,
uh,
what it really kind of means is that
we're the products,
um,
you know,
in our modern world of things that
happened to our ancestors maybe two or
300 years ago and maybe even the fears
like they think that Arachnophobia and
video phobia and a lot of the fears of
snakes and bugs and things that people
have might be directly attributed to
ancestors being bitten or poisoned by
those things.
Or a seeing someone getting bitten or
poisoned by them.
I mean,
speaking of that sort of thing.
And,
uh,
there's a section I do and when I'm
talking about the development of poisons
to try to eradicate coyotes,
uh,
and the,
cody America book where the reason
during World War II we decided are the
government what is now called wildlife
services,
um,
this agency that was trying to solve the
Predator problem by exterminating caio.
He's,
the reason they used our new chemical
insights during World War Two to come up
with new poisons a against coyotes,
was that they began to realize that
strychnine,
which had been the poison of preference
for the previous 70 or so years,
was a poison that kill coyotes too
quickly.
And coyotes are really smart about cause
and effect.
And so a coyote that was in the presence
of an animal that ate a bait cube and
then suddenly went into convulsions.
And strychnine produced these really
sort of bizarre and grotesque deaths
that those animals would not take a
strict nine bait after they saw that
happen to one of their pack members.
And so in the 19 forties,
we came up with three new poisons.
Uh,
one of them was call a sodium.
let's see,
sodium,
a floor Acetate,
which is the one we now call 10 80,
and it was called 10 80 and it was used
for the next 19 that was in fact,
it's still used in limited application
today,
but it was a poison that was developed
after 1080 tries by this laboratory that
assists 19 20th specialized in
developing poisons to kill a wolves and
coyotes.
It's called the eradication methods
laboratory.
So 10 80,
uh,
another one,
sodium foul medium was a poison that
kill coyotes so slowly that they would
often survive for a week after they ate
the poison.
And in that week their pads would fall
off,
their hair would fall off,
the village would come off their bodies.
Uh,
there's one story where a farmer in
Colorado found during the winter of
about 18 or 19,
47 or 48,
he found seven or eight coyotes in his
barn with no pads on their feet,
no hair on their bodies,
all huddled together trying to stay
warm.
She's,
and he killed them with a pitch fork.
Oh my God.
But the reason we introduced these
poisons,
and there was a third one too,
which was a cyanide,
uh,
basically the one that we call him 44
now that are little cartridges that fire
assign I'd missed into their mouths is
because these poisons killed them slowly
enough that other coyote is witnessing
the victim taking the bite of the poison
bait.
Didn't put two and two together.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean,
so we ha.
We even had these kinds of insights
about how animals will observe something
and preserve a memory of what they've
seen and then try to actually come up
with,
with a poison that plays against that.
Absolutely fascinating.
The whole,
the whole subject.
Absolutely fascinating.
Listen man,
I'm so glad we got together.
I want to get you together with Randall
Carlson though.
Would you be interested in coming back
and doing another shot?
I'd love to do that.
I would great to have you get together
with him and compare notes because he
has some really interesting observations
about these asteroidal impacts and I
think the two of you together would have
a fascinating conversation.
So let's do that down the line.
But until then,
your book,
Coyote America is fantastic.
I loved it.
Thank you very much for that.
And I'm going to.
I haven't started reading yet,
but American Serengeti is your other
book.
I'm sure it's equally awesome and I
really enjoyed this.
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks for having me,
man.
It's been great.
All right folks.
See you next week.
Bye.